ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN. BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL. PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORP BERG SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH STONE
TEEN BELLA THERE IS THE
APPROVED VIA VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER WICKS. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
WHERE MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT
IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS. IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN. IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD. THE
LIGHT OF YOUR GUIDANCE LEADS
ALL HUMANKIND. TO TRUTH JUSTICE
LIBERTY AND FREEDOM. GRANT US A
SHARE IN THE LIGHT OF YOUR
COUNTENANCE. BY GUIDING THESE
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
GATHERED HERE. IN LEGISLATING
FAIR ANALYZE LAWS FOR THE
GREATER GOOD OF THE PEOPLE OF
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN YOUR NAME WE PRAY I MEAN.
THANK YOU MOM YES SIR WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDINGAND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
KALRA. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. OF THE UNITED STATES.
INDIVISIBLE. THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY APRIL
TWENTY SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE ASSEMBLY REDDIT NINETY M.
THE HONORABLE REBEKAH
BARRICADED ASSISTANT SPEAKER
PRO TEMPORE THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF WORKS YOU
PROGRAM A DANCE RECORD DAVID
BOWMAN READING ROLES CALLED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK MCCORKLE
THE ASSEMBLY MOTION KERRY DOES
ANDREAS MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THE READING. OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENT OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BIGELOW. FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. FLORA. M. S. RAYOS. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY GONZALES CERVANTES
REYES BERMAN AND GIPSON TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PERCENT ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER. S. B. FOUR NINE
FOUR DODD FROM THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA THE FINAL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES NUMBER ONE TO
MEET THIS WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY
SIX AT ONE THIRTY PM IN ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN AND- TO ALLOW
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FOUR. TO MEET THIS THURSDAY MAY
TWENTY SEVEN AT NINE THIRTY AM
IN ROOM FOUR THREE SEVEN.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. THE SECOND READING
COVERING ASSEMBLY BILL. FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE ONE FOUR SEVEN NINE
FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN FORTY SIX FORTY EIGHT
FIFTY SIX SIXTY EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
NINETY TWO NINETY SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT NINETY NINE ONE HUNDRED
ONE A ONE ONE OH FIVE ONE OF
610-711-0118. ONE TWENTY THREE
ONE TWENTY FOUR ONE TWENTY SIX
TO FIFTEEN TO TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY FOUR.
TO TWENTY SIX TO
FORTY TO FIFTY TWO TO FIFTY
SEVEN TO SIXTY TWO TO SIXTY
EIGHT TO EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN TO NINETY TWO TO NINETY
THREE THREE TWELVE THREE
THIRTEEN THREE FIFTEEN THREE
SIXTY THREE TWENTY FIVE THREE
THIRTY ONE THREE FORTY THREE
FORTY TWO THREE FORTY FIVE
THREE FORTY NINE THREE FIFTY
SIX THREE SIXTY FOUR THREE
SIXTY NINE THREE THREE THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY  504-545-7460. ONE
FOUR SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE
FOUR SEVENTY FOUR FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT FORTY THREE FORTY SIX
FORTY EIGHT FOUR NINETY FOUR
NINETY EIGHT FORTY NINE FIVE
HUNDRED FIVE A. ONE FIVE ELEVEN
FIVE SIXTEEN FIVE TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY THREE FIVE TWENTY FIVE
BY. FORTY FIVE FORTY FIVE FIVE
FORTY FIVE FORTY FOUR FOUR FIVE
FORTY FIVE FIVE FORTY SEVEN
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN FIVE SIXTY ONE
FIVE SIXTY TWO FIVE SIX TWO
THREE. 705-765-7958
760-060-2604 615-624-6286
464-026-5360 766-267-6716
NINETY FIVE SEVEN A
1-710-716-7177. THIRTY ONE
SEVEN FORTY FOUR SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE SEVEN SIXTY
TWO SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
SEVEN NINETY SIX IT'LL SEVEN
EIGHT THIRTEEN EIGHT FIFTEEN A
SIXTEEN EIGHT TWENTY FIVE.
TWENTY SIX A TWENTY NINETY
SIXTY FIVE EIGHT SEVENTY TO
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT NINETY SIX
AND 907-098-9159. TWENTY ONE
NINE TWENTY FIVE NINE TWENTY
SEVEN NINE THIRTY NINE THIRTY
FOUR NINE THIRTY SEVEN NINE
SIXTY NINE SIXTY FIVE NINE
THIRTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR NINETY
NINE NINETY THREE NINETY FIVE
POINT NINETY EIGHT TOTAL THREE
TOTAL. NINE TEN FIFTEEN TEN
TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE TO
THIRTY FIVE TO THIRTY EIGHT TEN
FORTY. TEN FORTY ONE TO FIFTY
ONE TO FIFTY FIVE TO SEVENTY
ONE SINCE AT 1-082-108-4280.
FIVE TO EIGHTY SIX TO NINETY
FOUR ELEVEN HUNDRED ELEVEN OH
SIX ELEVEN TEN ELEVEN ELEVEN
ELEVEN THIRTEEN ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN TWENTY SO SIX
ELEVEN TWENTY SO. ELEVEN THIRTY
TO ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. LET
THIRTY NINE ELEVEN. SEVEN
FIFTY. ELEVEN A- THREE AND FIVE
ELEVEN NINETY. ELEVEN NINETY
TWO. ELEVEN NINETY FOUR TOTAL
ONE TOOL SEVEN TWELVE WAIT
TWELVE FIFTEEN TWELVE NINETEEN
TWELVE FORTY SIX OR FORTY EIGHT
TWELVE. 1-440-512-4072 ASSEMBLY
SIX OR THIRTY FOUR THIRTEEN
AWAIT THIRTEEN ELEVEN THIRTEEN
TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN TWENTY
SIX. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN. 611-356-1350.
SEVEN THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE FOURTEEN OH FIVE.
311-423-1420 NINE FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE. 571-454-4050. FIVE
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE
FOURTEEN. 661-474-1512. FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE
FIFTEEN THIRTY TO FIFTEEN
THIRTY THREE. 491-535-1530 SIX
FIFTEEN FORTY FIFTEEN FORTY TO.
751-568-1530 THREE FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE ADOPTED WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY TWO. 414-054-0750.
SEVEN SIXTY ONE SIXTY SIX
SEVENTY SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY
THREE ONE FOURTEEN ONE
SEVENTEEN. TO EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY FIVE TO
THIRTY THREE TO FIFTY FOUR. TO
FIFTY SIX THREE OH FIVE THREE
EIGHTEEN THREE FORTY THREE
THREE FORTY SEVEN THREE FIFTY
THREE SIXTY TO THREE TO SIXTY
SIX. SIXTY SEVEN THROUGH
752-914-1416 1-442-146-9471
FOUR EIGHT. FORTY FORTY ONE
FIVE TWELVE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
FIVE FORTY ONE. 808-552-6590
261-461-9620 565-651-6546 SIXTY
FIVE. SIX SIXTY SIX SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN OF 771-371-9720 ONE SEVEN
FIFTY THREE. 827-379-7948 AWAIT
814-817-8358 FORTY THREE FORTY
SEVEN EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT. EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT.
1-072-893-1940 ONE ON
429-405-9408 I 595-595-8960
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT. NINE NINETY
TOTAL 1-717-102-1220 THREE.
221-436-2406 SIXTY SIX AND
SEVEN TWO SEVEN TWO OF-
THRILLER OH FOUR. OH FIVE
ELEVEN THE ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
A LOT FIFTY EIGHT ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE TOOL FOR TWELVE FOURTEEN
TWELVE TWENTY THREE TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT. TWELVE FORTY TO
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN TWELVE FIFTY
TWELVE SIXTY ONE TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO THIRTEEN SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY THIRTY ONE.
711-371-1370 SEVEN FOURTEEN
TWENTY TO FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE.
1-131-524-1570 SIX AND ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY FIVE. NETWORK
DAVID ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO THE FILE. ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. THIS IS FILE ITEM
THREE SEVENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY THREE BY MISS DAVIES
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DAVIES AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO MARRIAGE DECLARING
HERE TO SEE THEIR UP TO THE
CORRECT IMMEDIATELY. THIS DAVIS
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
THREE THIS SIMPLE MEASURE SEEKS
TO CODIFY THE PRACTICE FOR
ELECTRONIC INCIDENTS OF
MARRIAGE LICENSE IN SOME
STATIONS ARE MUCH TO BE DONE TO
BE A LIVE INTERACTIVE VIDEO
TECHNOLOGY THAT CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES HAVE EMPLOYED OVER THE
LAST YEARS DURING THE PANDEMIC
I WANT TO GET WANT TO THANK MY
JOINT AUTHORS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR TRUSTING ME
TO CARRY THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
FORWARD. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND PASS POLICY
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS DAVIS MISTER
DAVID CHIU IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER JUST
VERY BRIEFLY APPRECIATE. THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THIS AS
THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE. WE KNOW THAT DURING
THIS PANDEMIC HAVE THERE BEEN
MANY WHO HAVE PUT ASIDE
MOMENTOUS OCCASIONS LIKE
MARRIAGE EQUALITY UP LIKE
MARRIAGE CEREMONIES. AND THE
FACT THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
VERY POPULAR DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD. OF ALLOWING COUNTIES TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A STORY- TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH. ALLOWING
MARRIAGE LICENSES TO BE ISSUED
REMOTE REMOTELY IS IMPORTANT SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
pTO. SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS OF.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. WELL AND
CLOSER ALL. CALVET AYE SIXTY NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES FILE ITEMS
THREE SEVENTY THREE THROUGH.
THREE SEVEN SEVEN. PASS RETAIN
THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT AB TWO FORTY FIVE. BY MR
CHIU THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU AND OTHERS
AN ACT RELATING TO EDUCATIONAL
QUALITY. MEMBERS. THE RETENTION
MISTER Q. MISTER CHAIR YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB TWO FORTY FIVE ADDRESSES
BARRIERS FACED BY TRANSGENDER
AND NON BINARY STUDENTS AT
SCHOOL AND IN THE WORKPLACE IF
A STUDENT DOESN'T HAVE AN
UPDATED DIPLOMA OR TRANSCRIPT
THEY CAN FACE CHALLENGES
APPLYING FOR JOBS OR GRADUATE
SCHOOL. DIPLOMAS REPRESENTATION
OF YEARS OF HARD WORK AND
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. IT
SHOULDN'T CAUSE STRESS OR
EMOTIONAL HARM BY HAVING
SOMEONE DEAD NAME ON IT. DUE TO
OUTDATED SCHOOL POLICIES. THIS
BILL BUILDING ON WORK FRM
PRIOR YEARS ALLOWS TRANSGENDER
AND NON BINARY STUDENTS AT
PUBLIC COLLEGES. TO HAVE THEIR
CHOSEN NAME PRINTED ON A
DIPLOMA WHEN THEY GRADUATE. IT
CREATES A STANDARD PROCESS FOR
UPDATING STUDENT RECORDS SO
NAMES AND GENDERS ARE
ACCURATELY REFLECTED. FANS AND
NON BINARY PEOPLE FACE MANY
BARRIERS THE NAME ON THE
DIPLOMA SHOULD NOT BE ONE OF
THEM AND WITH THAT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAGO.
THANKS CHOOSE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. THANK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER CHINA AS
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE I'M THREE SEVENTY
NINE AB NINE ONE FOUR BY MS
IRWIN COOKERY SOME PEOPLE NINE
FOURTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER IRWIN
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC GIRLS
SECONDARY EDUCATION IS IRWIN
EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB AT NINE ONE FOUR WILL
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
IMPORTANT INFORMATION REGARDING
THE EXTENT TO WHICH FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN ARE PREPARED TO
SUCCEED IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THIS DATA
WILL HELP THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINE HOW TO IMPROVE
COLLEGE READINESS PROGRAMS AND
CLOSE EQUITY GAPS IT GOT ACROSS
THE- CSU SYSTEM AS WE CONTINUE
TO MOVE AWAY FROM THE OUTDATED
REMEDIAL MODEL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
ONE. SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
THE CLUB THE ROLE MEMBERS. IT
IS ADAMANT. MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
TYLER AT I. SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES PASSED
RETAINING FILE ITEMS THREE
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY ONE AND
THREE EIGHTY TWO. THIS IS FILE
OUT OF THREE THREE AB THREE
THREE TWO DR CAR CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY TWO BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN A HAZARDOUS WASTE
IN THE CLEAR THE YEARS EITHER
OF SIGNIFICANT MEDIA ME. DR
COURT YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB THREE
THREE TWO AUTHORIZES TRIGGERED
WOULD WASTE TO BE MANAGED UNDER
ALTERNATIVE MANAGEMENT
STANDARDS INSTEAD OF BEING
MANAGED AS HAZARDOUS WASTE THE
ALTERNATIVE MAN MANAGEMENT
STANDARDS FOR TRADE WOULD RAISE
JUST PUT IN PLACE FOR DECADES.
THE LAST YEAR THE AUTHORIZATION
FOR THESE MANAGEMENT STANDARDS
SUNSET. AB THREE THREE TWO WILL
PROVIDE CERTAINTY TO THE
INDUSTRY BY PLACING THE
ALTERNATE MANAGER. MANAGEMENT
STANDARDS BACK INTO LAW THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR. SENIOR
DISCUSSION ON THE ADAM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AND OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY NOTES HERE ON THE
URGENCY I SEVENTY NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. THAT BILL PASSES
FILE ITEMS THREE EIGHTY FOUR.
THROUGH THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
PASSERINE TENNIS FILE ITEM
THREE NINE AB TEN FORTY TWO.
SEPARATE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND OTHERS
IMMACULATE IN A LONG TERM
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES MR JONES
SAWYER. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
SPEAKER I AM PRESENTING AB TEN
FORTY TWO TO MAKE SURE NO
COMPANY CAN ESCAPE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF PROVIDING
SUBSTANDARD CARE TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO BROADEN THE SCOPE TO
SEEK PAYMENT FOR UNPAID NURSING
HOME VIOLATIONS FROM AFFILIATED
BUSINESSES OWNED OR CONTROLLED
BY THE LICENSEE.OF THE SKILLED
NURSING HOME NURSING HOMES
BECAME THE MOST DANGEROUS PLACE
TO LIVE AND WORK DURING THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC WITH
NEARLY THIRTEEN THOUSAND LIVES
LOST AT THESE FACILITIES DUE TO
NEGLIGENCE AND UNSAFE PRACTICES
COMPLEX OWNERSHIP STRUCTURES
HAVE ALLOW BAD ACTORS TO
OBSCURE FINANCIAL ASSETS AND
LIMIT THEIR LEGAL EXPOSURE TO
TRUE ACCOUNTABILITY. THESE
TYPES OF COMPANIES ARE BETTER
KNOWN AS AFFILIATED PARTIES FOR
CLARITY READ RELATED PARTIES
ARE COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE A
WIDE VARIETY OF BUSINESS
SERVICES TO NURSING HOMES AT
THE SAME OWNER IN EFFECT THESE
LICENSEES CAN SECURE THEIR
FINANCIAL ASSETS AND MAKE THE
BUSINESS STRUCTURE SO
COMPLICATED THAT ENFORCEMENT OF
PENALTIES IT DIFFICULT. AS
RESULT NEARLY SIX MILLION IN
CITATIONS REMAIN OUTSTANDING
DEBT NURSING FACILITIES HAVE
FAILED TO PAY FOR QUALITY OF
CARE BY EXPANDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH CAN
HOLD RESPONSIBLE FOR SERIOUS
PATIENT VIOLATIONS THIS BILL
WILL HELP ENSURE THE STATE HAS
THE PROPER TOOLS TO COLLECT AND
PAY FEES FROM COMPANIES AND
INCENTIVIZE ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED IN THE OPERATION. OF
NURSING HOMES TO PROVIDE
QUALITY CARE AB TEN FORTY TWO
RIVERS SEEPED OUT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR EITHER. THANK JOHNSON.
C. DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. CLICK LIBERAL. WHAT IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF- THANK. CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE I FIFTY FIVE MINUTES
THIRTEEN. THE MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM THREE NINETY
THREE. THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE
NINETY FOUR EIGHTY TWO FORTY
TWO BY MR HOLDEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
UTILITIES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION- FOR MISTER
HOLDING EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWO
FORTY TWO IS A CODE CLEAN A
BILL THAT MAKES A NUMBER. OF
TECHNICAL CHANGES IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE IT STREAMLINES
EFFORTS BY THE CPUC TO MEET
THEIR LEGISLATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS IT ALSO ADDS
CLARIFICATIONS ON ELIGIBILITY
TO ACCESS THE WILDFIRE FUND
WHICH WILL INCREASE PROTECTIONS
FOR RATEPAYERS IT IS RECEIVED
NO OPPOSITION OR NO VOTES NO
VOTES. COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU HOLDEN.
SENIOR DISCUSSION ON THE ADAM.
CARPAL OF THE ROLE. SACRAMENTO
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE EVENT I
SIXTY SIX. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. PASS RETAIN OF OUR
THREE NAY FIVE THIS IS FILE AND
THREE NINETY SIX AB TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE MAYES RUBIO
EMAIL MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
SEEKS TO AMEND THE PENAL CODE
SECTION RELATING TO EXPUNGEMENT
TO SPECIFIC TO SPECIFY THAT
THIS THAT THE DISMISSAL OF A
CASE UNDER THOSE SECTIONS WOULD
NOT AUTOMATICALLY RELIEVE A
DEFENDANT. FROM THE TERM OF AN
EXPIRED TEN YOUR CRIMINAL
PROTECTIVE ORDER ISSUED IN THE
CASE THESE TENURE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS ARE ONLY ISSUED IN THAT
CERTAIN SERIOUS CASES SUCH AS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STALKING AND
ELDER ABUSE THE ORDER PLAYS A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN PROTECTING
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
VICTIMS. IN A VIOLENT CRIME.
CRIMINAL PROTECTIVE ARE NOT
PUNITIVE IN NATURE THEY ARE NON
PENAL RESTRICTIONS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT CRIME VICTIMS. THE BILL
IN FRONT OF HE COMMITTEE TODAY
DOES NOT. REQUIRE THAT
PROTECTIVE ORDERS REMAIN IN
PLACE IN ALL CASES IT MERELY
PRESERVE JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO
TERMINATE OR MODIFY AN ORDER
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND ENJOYS SUPPORT
FROM CRIME VICTIMS ADVOCACY
GROUPS. THE BILL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. TAKING
HIS RUBIO MR SAY ARE TELL IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SPEAKER MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY I STAND IN SUPPORT AND
IS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE. FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR CHAMPIONING THIS
BILL AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
PRESERVES AND PROTECTS VICTIMS
OF CRIME TO THE USE OF
PROTECTIVE ORDERS. THIS IS A
COMMONSENSE POLICY AND WILL
ENSURE THAT WE PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS FROM FURTHER INJURY
OR HARASSMENT IT IS FOR THAT
REASON I S. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
THEY WISH THEY TO THANK YOU MS
RUBIO WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS. THREE NINETY SEVEN.
THROUGH THREE NINETY NINE PASS
AND RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOUR HUNDRED AB ELEVEN A ONE
TIME IS IRWIN CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN A ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. MEASUREMENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AB
ELEVEN NO ONE WILL PROVIDE
CLARITY ON EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I AUTHORED AB
TWENTY NINE TWELVE THAT UPDATED
THE TOOLS AVAILABLE FOR HOAS TO
PREVENT FRAUDULENT ACTIVITIES
WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW. AB
ELEVEN OH ONE AS A TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP MEASURE THAT DIRECTLY
RESPONDS TO IMPLEMENTATION
CONCERNS FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT OUR
EFFORTS TO COMBAT FRAUD ARE
CLEAR SAID THAT HOAS CAN
EFFECTIVELY PROTECT THEIR
FUNDS. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
MISSOURI SENIOR DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. THE
START OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
AND ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A- YOU. HELLO. WELL
CLOSER ALL TIED BUT I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM FOR A ONE A.
B. TWELVE FORTY THREE. CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOCKER
RUBIO AND OTHERS AND I BELIEVE
IN THE PROTECTIVE ORDERS MS
RUBIO THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FORTY
THREE LEGISLATION THAT WILL
EXPAND THE ELDER ABUSE
INDEPENDENT ADULTS OF A
PROTECTION ACT OR E. A. D. A C.
P. A. DUE TO THE ONGOING COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC VISITATION TO
VULNERABLE GROUPS INCLUDING
ELDERLY INDIVIDUALS HAS BEEN
LIMITED TO PREVENT MINIMIZE OR
MINIMIZE EXPOSURE TO THE VIRUS
FOR MANY FAMILIES CARING FOR
RELATIVES AND COMMUNITY IN
COMMUNITY THIS MEANT LITTLE TO
NO VEGETATION OUTSIDE THE
PRIMARY CARE GIVERS. AB TWELVE
FORTY THREE WOULD PROVIDE
RECOURSE TO PREVENT AND ADDRESS
ISOLATION OF VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS BY ALLOWING
INDIVIDUALS WITH PRE EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS AS DEFINED TO
PETITION THE COURT THROUGH THE
EXISTING ELDER AND DEPENDENT
ADULT ABUSE RESTRAINING ORDER
PROCESS AFTER NOTICING HEARING
COURT FINDINGS CAN BE USED TO
ALLOW CONTACT OR PREVENT
ISOLATION SO LONG AS THE ELDER
OR DEPENDENT ADULT WANTS THE
CONTACT AB TWELVE FORTY THREE
ALSO PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
ELDER AND DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
RESTRAINING ORDER REMEDY FOR
FINANCIAL ABUSE BY EXTENDING AB
TWENTY FIVE SIX OF SEVENTEEN GO
GLORIA OF TWENTY TWENTY TO
ALLOW JUDGES ISSUING ELDER AND
DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. TO MAKE
SIMILAR FINDINGS THAT SPECIFIC
DEBTS ARE THE RESULT OF COURSE
DEBT THIS WILL GIVE THE PRECISE
PROTECTED PARTY AN ADDITIONAL
TOOL TO USE WHEN FACING
COLLECTION ACTIVITY BY
CREDITORS AND COLLECTORS THEY
CAN USE THE COURSE DEBT FINING
TO DISPUTE DEBTS WITH CREDITORS
COLLECTORS AND OUR CREDIT
REPORTING AGENCIES WHICH WILL
PROTECT THEIR FUTURE INCOME AND
FACILITATE THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY THIS BILL ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WE PLAN
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH PART
II WITH PARTNERS AND JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IN THE SENATE IF NEED
BE. THANK. YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK THIS REVIEW. C.
NOTICE. FOR DEBATE ON THE I
DON'T CARPAL OF THE ROLE. THESE
ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT
ABOUT. CLARK WELL. THOSE ARE
ALL TIED AT I. SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM FOR- TO.
M. FOUR OH THREE THIS IS FILE
ITEM FOUR OH FOUR AB TEN SIXTY
TWO BY MR MATHIS CALGARY
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS AN
ACCOLADE TO GUARDIANS A GOOD
SERVERS. MISTER MATHIS YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TEN SIXTY TWO
REQUIRES A CONSERVATOR OR
GUARDIAN TO PROVIDE A WRITTEN
FIFTEEN DAY NOTICE. BEFORE
DISPOSING OF VALUE LIST ITEMS
AS WELL AS A DESCRIPTION OF THE
PROPERTY AND ITEMS AND TO
PROVIDE REASONABLE ACCESS TO IT.
CURRENTLY THIS VALUE LIST
PROPERTY COULD BE SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS- YOUR GRANDFATHER'S
OLD WAR SCRAPBOOK WITH PHOTOS.
THEY CAN BE THROWN AWAY IN
MEMORIES LOST FOREVER. CAN BE
YOUR GREAT GRANDMOTHER'S
WEDDING DRESS. OR HER NEEDLE
NAY THIS BILL SIMPLY ENSURES
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO KEEP THOSE
ITEMS KEEP THOSE MEMORIES AND
SHARE THAT WITH FUTURE
GENERATIONS MEMBERS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLARK
LIBERAL. SEVERAL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THEM. ALL MEMBERS WILL
DECIDE ABOUT. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT. I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASSER ATTAIN ON FILE ITEMS
FOUR OH FIVE AND FOR- SIX.
MEMBERS. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OUR OBSERVANCE. IN HONOR OF
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW ARE YOU
READY TO PROCEED ON FILE ITEM.
FOR FIFTY THREE. CLERK WILL
READ H. R. FORTY TWO. HOUSE
RESOLUTION FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE
MONTH. MR LOW YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES FOR
ALLOWING US TO RECOGNIZE ME AS
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE
MONTH AS YOU KNOW THIS HAS BEEN
A CONTINUOUS CONVERSATION OVER
THE PAST YEAR AND BEYOND ABOUT
HELPING TO HELP LIFT THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY AND
WE CANNOT TALK ABOUT THE ASIAN
AMERICAN EXPERIENCE WITHOUT
HELPING TO RECOGNIZE THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND SOLIDARITY WITH
OTHER COMMUNITIES. SIMILARLY I
ALSO WANT TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO OUR- FOLDER HERE
WITH RESPECT TO RECOGNIZING THE
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
EXCELLENCE AWARDS AND
RECOGNISING THE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF MANY IN OUR COMMUNITY THIS
YEAR OUR CAUCUS HAS. RECOGNIZED
AND HONORED MANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE. TAKEN IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO HELP STOP THE API
HATE AND THE COMMUNITIES. THEY
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENGAGING WHEN NO ONE ELSE WOULD
AND WE THANK THEM FOR THEIR
CONTINUED SERVICE. AT THE SAME
TIME IT'S ALSO ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THAT WE NEED TO DO BETTER
OURSELVES. AND AGAIN CALLING
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE LIST OF
ASIAN FOR SILENT OR LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS MEMBERS. WE ALSO.
RECOGNIZED MUCH WORK TO BE DONE.
OUT OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
LEGISLATORS HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
WE ONLY HAVE ONE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER WOMAN. AND WE THANK
ASSEMBLY WARNED JANET NGUYEN
FOR HER SERVICE. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE CAN BE DOING MORE.
AND WE WANT TO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE SOME
STRONG ASIAN FOOTBALLER WOMEN
WE HAVE CREATED A LEGACY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
FORMER SECRETARY STATE MARCH
FONG EU. FORMER CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER OF THIS
BODY MAINLY TOM. WHOSE LEGACY
CONTINUES IN THIS BODY TODAY
THROUGH HER DAUGHTER STEPHANIE
TAMBA CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR OUR
ASIAN PROVIDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS WE ALSO RECOGNIZE FORMER
ASSEMBLYWOMAN JUDY CHU
CURRENTLY IN CONGRESS SERVING
AS THE CHAIR OF THE CAL OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER CONGRESSIONAL CAUCUS.
OR STEWARDS OF FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AS OUR
CONSTITUTION OFFICERS AND FIONA
MA AS STATE TREASURER AND THEN
HE AND STATE COMPTROLLER.
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE MUCH WORK TO
BE. TO DO COLLECTIVELY. ON YOUR
DRESS ARE A FEW MEMENTOS I WANT
TO CELEBRATE OUR CULTURE. ALL
RIGHT HERE TO CELEBRATE OUR
CULTURE. AND OUR HERITAGE- BUT
ALSO. I LIKE TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO A WHISTLE ALWAYS
SAW A YELLOW WHISTLE. THAT
UNFORTUNATELY WAS SPAWNED BY.
THE REASON áP I HATE. WHILE A
MODEST EFFORT IN DISTRIBUTING
TEN THOUSAND WHISTLES THIS HAS
NOW TURNED INTO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND WHISTLES THROUGHOUT
THE MONTH OF MAY FOR ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH.
US A SIMPLE TOOL FOR SELF
PROTECTION BUT A POWERFUL ONE
THAT SIGNIFIES THE IMPORTANCE
OF FIGHTING ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER HATE IF YOU SEE
SOMETHING. SAY SOMETHING AND WE
ASKING FOR SO THEY'RE AN ALLY
SHIP IN RECOGNIZING MAY AS
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE
MONTH AND EFFECTIVELY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR LOW.
MISSION ONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER-
BEFORE I MAKE A COMMENT I DO
ALSO WANT TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION THE ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS. LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
DOES NOT HAVE ANY REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS ON HERE SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT YOU RECOGNIZE
THAT AND REALIZE THAT IT'S
REALLY UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE- I
REMEMBER MY DAYS WHEN I WAS IN
THE SENATE WE WERE PART OF THE
CAUCUS. WE WERE ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE I WAS THERE IN
MEETINGS RETREATS SIX SURGERY
AND WE ALSO PART OF BEING ABLE
TO. MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
HONOREES- I'M SHOCKED TO SEE
THIS TODAY I'M NOT REALLY SAD
TO SEE IT TODAY THAT AFTER TWO
YEARS I'VE LEFT. THIS IS WHAT
WE'VE GOTTEN OURSELVES INTO. ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMAN'S CAUCUS IN MY DISTRICT
WHICH HAS THE LARGEST BEEN MISS
AMERICA POPULATION OUTSIDE
VIETNAM. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR FORTY SEVEN RECOGNIZING API
HERITAGE MONTH. WE CELEBRATE
API HERE JUST MONTHS
COMMEMORATE THE SIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER EXPERIENCE AND
THE MANY STORIES OF THE
FAMILIES WHO CAME TO AMERICA
FOR A BETTER LIFE. CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO OVER SIX MILLION
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE. MY COMMUNITY AN ORANGE
COUNTY IS HOME TO THE THIRD
LARGEST NUMBER OF ASIAN
AMERICAN OWNED BUSINESSES IN
THE UNITED STATES WHAT OVER
SIXTY THREE THOUSAND ASIAN
AMERICAN OWNED BUSINESSES
COUNTY WIDE. THE MONTH OF MAY
WAS CHOSEN TO REMEMBER THE
IMMIGRATION THE FIRST JAPANESE
TO UNITED STATES ON MAY SEVENTH
EIGHTEEN FORTY THREE. AND TO
MARK THE ANNIVERSARY OF THE
COMPLETION OF THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD ON
MAY TENTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE
THE MAJORITY WORKERS RELATED
TRACKS. IN CHINESE IMMIGRANTS.
CHINESE INDIAN FILIPINO
VIETNAMESE KOREAN JAPANESE
MANGA AND MANY OTHER GROUPS
HAVE MADE AMAZING STRIDES. IN
ACHIEVING SUCCESS THROUGH HARD
WORK BUT THERE IS STILL MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE. DISCRIMINATION
HATE CRIMES AND THE ASIAN
AMERICAN INDUSTRY THAT HAVE
BEEN SINGLED OUT IN OUR STATES
LEGISLATION. I AM FIGHTING TO
MAKE SURE THAT NOT ONLY THAT
WERE THE WORK OF THIS IMPORTANT
COMMUNITY AND THESE
COMMUNITIES. IS RECOGNIZED BUT
THAT WE ARE TREATED FAIRLY. I
HAVEN'T BEEN THE FIRST
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN ELECTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE IN
THE NATION. N. YES THE ONLY.
FEMALE API THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATOR MANY OTHERS HAVE
JOINED ME IN PAVING THE WAY TO
REPRESENT OUR COMMUNITY AND
GOVERNMENT TODAY WE STILL GET
TO CELEBRATE THE FOURTEENTH API
ELECTED OFFICIAL REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS AND NOW
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATOR.
AND WE ALSO HAD IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE SENT TO FIRST CREATE AN
AMERICAN WOMAN TWO OF THEM FROM
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSWOMAN YOUNG
KIM FORMER STATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND ALSO MACHEL STILL TO
CONGRESS. THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL SO THAT WE CAN RECOGNIZE.
THE ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
BUSINESSES WORKERS AND FAMILIES
WHO CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH TO OUR
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISSED ONE MISTER GIBSON IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR SCHISM- MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF HR FORTY
TWO. AS WE CELEBRATE A
RECOGNIZE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER HERITAGE AND A ONE
UNDERSCORE IT REFLECTS ALSO MY
FAMILY THAT I HAVE PACIFIC
ISLANDERS AND PROUD OF IT.
MEMBERS AS WE STAND TOGETHER IN
SOLIDARITY. WITH OUR AGE WITH
OUR API BROTHERS AND SISTERS WE
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE CONTINUE
RESEARCH OF THE API.
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE UNDER
ATTACK. IT BREAKS MY HEART.
THAT WE ARE STILL DISCUSSING
THE RESEARCH OF HATE CRIMES IN
NOW IS THERE TO CALIFORNIA BUT
ALSO ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. ASIAN AMERICANS.
NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY ARE
EXPERIENCING A HEIGHTENED LEVEL
OF DISCRIMINATION BULLYING AS
WELL AS HARASSMENT. THE
INCREASE OF USE OF ANTI AGENT
RHETORIC HAS RESULTED IN ASIAN
AMERICANS BEING HARASSED
ASSAULTED. AND SCAPEGOATED
DURING THIS PANDEMIC DURING
TIMES OF HARDSHIP WE SHOULD
COME TOGETHER AND UNITE AGAINST
THIS HATE I STAND AS LONG
SOLIDARITY WITH ETHNOLOGY IS
CELEBRATING ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER- TO TOMATO AND ASK FOR
A STRONG AYE VOTE ON HR FORTY
TWO. THANK YOU MS GIBSON MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ABOUT
HALF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I RISE SUPPORT OF
HR FORTY TWO PROCLAIMING MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH WELL MAYBE
SHE'LL BE SEIZE MISSION TO THE
MANY EQUITY AND INCLUSION IT'S
IMPERATIVE FOR ALL OF US IN
THIS BODY IN STATE TO FIGHT TO
ELIMINATE DISPARITIES BETWEEN
RACIAL GROUPS. AS MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FAMOUSLY STATED
INJUSTICE ANYWHERE IS A THREAT
TO JUSTICE EVERYWHERE WHAT WE
DO AFFECTS OTHERS AND WHAT
OTHERS DO WILL EVENTUALLY
AFFECT US MUST ACT FOR OTHERS
NOT ONLY FOR OURSELVES THEY
WOULD GATHER IN UNITY TO NAILS
HATE INSTANCE SIDE BY SIDE IN
SUPPORT OF OUR API BROTHERS AND
SISTERS MORE IMPORTANTLY
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
SOCIETY THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
HAVE MADE TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
IN ECONOMY AS A WHOLE I'D BE
REMISS NOT TO MENTION IN THE PP
I LEADER MY DISTRICT MESA
KAMOTO WHO MADE A HUGE IMPACT
IN EDUCATION AND CIVIL RIGHTS
THE SACRAMENTO AREA IN THE
NATION HER WORKING I'VE
ADVOCACY WITH INTERMENT
INSTRUMENTAL IN ADOPTING A PP I
HISTORY CURRICULUM ACROSS THE
STATE SHE ALSO PLAYED A PIVOTAL
ROLE IN THE EFFORTS THAT LED
THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. MEMBERS
OF THE HALF OF THE C. L. B. C.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH RESPECTFULLY.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE. THANK MISTER COOPER
LEE YOUR- THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LGBT Q.
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HOUSE
RESOLUTION FORTY TWO. TODAY WE
HONOR AAPI HERITAGE MONTH
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO SIX POINT
THREE MILLION ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICANS MORE THAN
ANY STATE IN OUR COUNTRY. THE
API COMMUNITIES PLAY A PIVOTAL
ROLE IN SHAPING THIS NATION
FROM BUILDING THE TRANS CONSUL
RAILROAD TO ADVOCATING FOR
LABOR LAW CHANGES IN THE DELANO
STRIKE. DESPITE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THE API API
COMMUNITY HAS MADE MANY STILL
FACE DISCRIMINATION AND HATE
FILLED BY FEAR. IT'S THE SAME
DISCRIMINATION THAT THE LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY AS FACE AND IT
IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO FIGHT
FOR A MORE INCLUSIVE. AND
EQUITABLE SOCIETY FOR ALL AS
YOU COMMEMORATED HARVEY MILK
FOR HIS CONTRIBUTIONS LAST WEEK
SOMETHING TO HIGHLIGHT WAS HOW
FORWARD THINKING HE WAS AT HIS
ORGANIZING. HARVEY MILK BUILT A
PROGRESSIVE COALITION SAN
FRANCISCO THEY INCLUDED THEAPI
COMMUNITY WITH FOUGHT IN
SOLITARY TO ADVANCE THE RIGHTS
OF THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY. IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEAGUE BECAME THE FIRST
NATIONAL CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION TO PUBLICLY
ENDORSE MARRIAGE EQUALITY. AND
FOR OUR- API COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ARE ALSO PART OF THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY THIS SOLIDARITY IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER.
HISTORICALLY OPENLY QUEER ASIAN
AMERICANS HAVE EMERGED AS KEY
ORGANIZER'S IN ISSUES RANGING
FROM IMMIGRATION TO FIGHT
AGAINST AIDS. AND THIS WEEK'S
FIRST QUEER AND TRANS ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER WE CONCERNED
CISCO KICKED OFF ON HARVEY
MILK'S BIRTHDAY. THE STRIDES
THAT THESE LEADERS HAVE MADE
TOGETHER AND BUILDING THESE
INTERSECTIONAL COALITIONS. HAVE
BROUGHT PROGRESS WE MUST
CONTINUE TO FIGHT TOGETHER.
THIS HERITAGE MONTH HONORS OUR
HISTORY CULTURE AND
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY THE AAPI
COMMUNITY WITHIN RICH AMERICA'S
HISTORY AND CERTAINLY ENRICH
OUR LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY. FOR
THESE REASONS IN CELEBRATION OF
SOLIDARITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE LATER FORTY
TWO. THANK YOU MISLI DR CHOI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU A
SPEAKER AND A MEMBERS. I RISE
OR SO IN CELEBRATION OF THIS
ALL- MAY AS A SHOWN ARE.
HERITAGE IN MIND AS WE HAVE
BEEN DOING EVERY MONTH. AS YOU
MAY KNOW- JANUARY THIRTEENTH SO
WE'VE BEEN CELEBRATING KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY BUT- A MONTH OF-
ME HAS BEEN CELEBRATED AS A
ASIAN HERITAGE MONTH. THIS
RESOLUTION IS SO IMPORTANT IN
THE WAKE OF- ASIAN HATE CRIME
BEING- PORTRAYED ALL OVER THE
STATE AND- NOR SAW ALL COUNTRY
AND THIS IS A VERY TIME NEED TO
REMIND EVERYONE HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS SO WE STAND TOGETHER AS
AMERICANS SO AND THE ANA ALWAYS
DEFINE- BACKGROUND AND. A
CULTURAL HERITAGES. AS THE TEXT
ABOUT. STATES CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO OVER SIX POINT THREE OR
SIX ONE FOUR MILLION ASIAN. AND
THE PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICANS
MORE THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
ASIAN AND THE PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS ARE ALSO ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING ETHNIC
POPULATIONS SO IN THE STATE.
HAVE A STROLLER SO IN THE
NATION IT IS IMPORTANT NOT TO
RECOGNIZE THE BENEFITS THAT OUR
VIBRANT. IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
SUFFERING TOOK CALIFORNIA AND
THE UNITED STATES ACROSS THE
SECTIONS ARE OF WHAT ECONOMY
SCIENCE EDUCATION POLITICS SO
ARE AND NOT EVERY AUTO SECTOR.
SO THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE. I
STAND HERE BEFORE YOU A TO.
SOME PROBLEM KOREAN IMMIGRANT
WHO IS SO DREAMS OR MADE THE
POSSIBLE OR IN THE INCREDIBLE
THE LAND OF OPPORTUNITY HERE IN
AMERICA THIS OF RESOLUTIONS
CELEBRATES THE PROMISE OF
AMERICA AND THE INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE MADE BY THE
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
BROUGHT US AND ASSIST US. THANK
YOU AGAIN HARD TO MY COLLEAGUES
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN THE
BRING UP THIS AND PUT ON OUR
RESOLUTION YEAH BY YEAR- TO
INTRODUCE- AND THEN ALSO TO
RECOGNIZE TO ORDER TO GET. THE
IMPORTANCE OF ALL ASIAN
HERITAGE MONTH- I ASK YOU TO
AVOID ON THIS- IMPORTER MAJEL
H. R. FORTY TWO YOU ARE EVIL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR CHOI.
MISTER SUN. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATIVE LATINO CAUCUS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR FIFTY
FORTY TWO FOR CLAIMING ME AS
ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. AND I
RISE WITH THE SEVERAL TORY
SPIRITS OF THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT API COMMUNITY HAS DONE IN
OUR COUNTRY OUR STATE TYPICALLY
THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT. I
HAVE BUT I ALSO RISE WHAT WITH
A HEAVY HEART. AND MOVED TO
SEOUL TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'VE
JUST GONE THROUGH WITH ACROSS
THE COUNTRY PARTICULARLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND MY DISTRICT.
WHAT WITH THE INCREASED
INCIDENCES OF API HATE IN THE
INCREASED- CRIMES TOWARDS API'S
IT ACROSS CALIFORNIA. MOST OF
YOU KNOW I REPRESENT CREATE
TOWN WHRE LARGEST POPULATIONS
BY THE LARGEST POPULATION OF
KOREANS OUTSIDE KOREA BUT ALSO
REPRESENT LITTLE TOKYO AND RICH
DIVERSITY. OF ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES WITH MY DISTRICT
AND WHAT WHAT WE'VE SEEN HAPPEN
IN MY DISTRICT HAPPEN ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WHERE FOLKS
MADE. RACIAL SLURS THAT WE- NOW
WE CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE HAVING TO
HEAR. IF YOU'RE A SENIOR WHO'S
WALKING ACROSS THE STREET
PEOPLE THROUGH THINGS AT
SENIORS IN OUR DISTRICT. KIDS
WERE MADE FUN OF. WALK AROUND
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD ALL SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF WHO THEY WORK. AND
WE SALAS WE CALLED IT OUT ONLY
TO FIND OUT THAT HOURS LATER.
THE ASSAULTS WOULD GET WOULD
GET STRONGER AND WE SAW THE
VANDALISM INCREASE. BUT WHAT WE
TOOK AWAY FROM IT. WE TOOK AWAY
FROM IT THAT WE NEEDED TO BUILD
THAT COALITION. THAT UNITED
FRONT TO CALL IT OUT FOR WHAT
IT WAS. AND TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T ACCEPT IT. AND IF IT WAS
NOT OKAY EVEN OUR OWN. TO MAKE
FUN. AN API IF WE IF WE SAW
THIS HAPPEN ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
IT'S WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I
HAD TO SAY THAT BECAUSE- IN OUR
DISTRICT WE SAW AN INCREASED
AMOUNT OF CRIMES INSTANCES. AND
WE HAVE TO CALL IT OUT. FOR
WHAT IT IS AND STAND IN UNITY.
STAND BESIDE AND NEVER WAVERED
DOWN. WHEN SOMEBODY
DISCRIMINATED ON. EFFORT THAT'S
SPIRITED HEAVY HEART AND
SETTLER TOOK A SETTLER TORY.
FEELING THAT WE RISE IN SUPPORT
AND HR FORTY TWO THANK YOU. I
THINK IT WAS SANTIAGO MISTER
BERMAN. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES ARRESTED
THEM TO HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF H. R. FORTY TWO THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES THE
HISTORY ACHIEVEMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICANS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER SIX
POINT THREE MILLION ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICANS MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN THE API
COMMUNITY ITSELF REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY. THIS
RESOLUTION HIGHLIGHTS THE MORE
THAN THIRTY DIVERSE ANCESTRIES
ENCOMPASSED API COMMUNITY. A.
B. I. AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH
IS A TIME TO CELEBRATE THE
DIVERSE CULTURES OF THE API
COMMUNITY AND RECOGNIZE THEIR
DURING CONTRIBUTIONS IN ART.
BUSINESS EDUCATION
ENTERTAINMENT FASHION
HUMANITIES LAW MEDICINE SCIENCE
SPORTS TECHNOLOGY IN GOVERNMENT
BOTH IN THE NATION'S CAPITAL
AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WELL
THIS MONTH IS A TIME FOR
CELEBRATION WE CANNOT FORGET
THAT ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS OF ALSO IN TOWARD
EXCLUSION DISCRIMINATION AND
XENOPHOBIA. IN SOME OF THE
DARKEST TIMES IN OUR HISTORY.
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE ALL KNOW
TOO WELL THE SCAPEGOATING OF
THE API COMMUNITY IS NOT
LIMITED TO OUR PAST BUT IS
UNFORTUNATELY PERVASIVE TODAY.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST THE VIOLENCE AND RACISM
THAT THE API COMMUNITY HAS
FACED AND CONTINUES TO FACE IN
OUR OWN DISTRICTS. THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY STANDS IN SOLIDARITY
WITH API COMMUNITY IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST HATRED AND INTOLERANCE
AND WE ARE PROUD TO RECOGNIZE
THE THING THIS MONTH. AS ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS I ESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON HR
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU MISS
BERMAN. MISTER CALDERON. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS IS AN
HONOR TO JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES OF BOTH THOSE THAT
ARE MEMBERS OF THE- LEGISLATURE
CAUCUS AS WELL AS THE OTHERS
THAT ARE STANDING UP IN SUPPORT
AND SOLIDARITY. IN RECOGNITION.
OF ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. AND AS
THE FIRST INDIAN AMERICAN THE
FIRST SOUTH ASIAN. THE PERSON
THE AMERICAN TO SERVE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE LEGISLATURE I
WANNA ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH
ASIAN COMMUNITY CERTAINLY
EXTEND APPRECIATION. TO
APPRECIATION TO THE API CAUCUS
OF FOR THE CONTINUAL
RECOGNITION OF THE GROWING
SOUTH ASIAN COMMUNITY.
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. AND THE
HISTORY WE HAVE NOT ONLY IN
TERMS OF BEING A PART OF THE
LEGACY CALIFORNIA SINCE. THE
NINETEENTH CENTURY BUT THEY
INCREASED EMPOWERMENT IN CIVIL
CIVIC SERVICE. WE HAVE TO-
CURRENT COUNCILLORS. AND
ULTRAMARATHON OTHER CURRENTLY
SERVING- AT THIS TIME- WE ALSO
OF COURSE HAVE OUR VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS WHO IS
SO INCREDIBLY SERVING NOT JUST
THE NATION BUT- I KNOW WE'RE
ALSO VERY PROUD OF HER. AS A
CALIFORNIA AND- WHENEVER SHE
SAID BUT WITH THE MOMENT YOU
STEP INTO THAT ROLE NEVER SHE
TAKES THE STAGE WE KNOW THAT.
SHE'S ONE OF OURS AND SHE IS A
VERY PROUD A SOUTH ASIAN
AMERICAN AND SPEAKS- VERY WELL
TO IT ESPECIALLY HER
EXPERIENCES WITH HER MOTHER WHO
I KNOW WOULD BE VERY PROUD OF
HER. TODAY AND FINALLY I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T REFER
MAKE MENTION TO THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN POLICY NUMBER EVER
DOLLOP SING SONG. WHO WAS FROM
THE IMPERIAL VALLEY AND WHO
ACTUALLY WAS NOT. ALLOWED TO
BECOME A CITIZEN AT THE TIME
WHEN HE FIRST CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES WAS ABLE TO GET
HIS EDUCATION THANKS TO SUPPORT
FROM THE FIRST GULF WATER. IN
THE- HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY IN
STOCKTON. ARE THEY HELPED TO
FUND HIS EDUCATION HE WENT ON.
TO NOT ONLY ENSURE HIS OWN
CITIZENSHIP BUT- HE FOUGHT
PERCENT FOR CITIZENSHIP FOR ALL
SOUTH ASIANS AND THEN QUICKLY
BECAME A JUDGE THE VENTURE
BECAME A CONGRESS MEMBER WHO
SET UP. ALL ALONG SIDE THE BILL
HI COMMUNITY FIGHTING FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS FOR EVERYONE- AND- IT'S
IN HIS HONOR. AND HIS HIS. TO
ALLOW SOMEONE LIKE ME TO. AND
SO I'M SOBRE TO ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES FOR STANDING WITH
US. IN RECOGNIZING- THE AAPI
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS VERY CHALLENGING MOMENT.
IN OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY LET
ALONE IN THE AAPI COMMUNITY AND
SO WITH THAT- I. AM GRATEFUL
THAT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE- THE GREAT
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR COMMUNITY
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE RESOLUTION. MR LOW WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. MEMBERS THIS FIRST
ROLE WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION CLERK
WILL OFFER THE RIGHT. HOME
AUTHORS. ON HOUSE RESOLUTION
FORTY TWO THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ADDING TO THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. YEAH. WELL. CLOSE ZERO
THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED THAT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE- SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS FOR THIS SEVENTEENTH
ASSEMBLY OBSERVANCE OF ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH WE WILL
RECOGNIZE A NUMBER OF
DISTINGUISHED HONOREES BECAUSE
OF THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
OUR HONOREES ARE NOT PRESENT.
BUT WE WANT TO SHARE THEIR
NAMES THE CATEGORY OF
RECOGNITION AND SOME
BIOGRAPHICAL INFORMATION ABOUT
THEM. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
RECOGNITION OF THE ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH HONOREES FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ. OUR FIRST HONOREE IS
DANIEL DAE KIM. HE IS THE
HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN ARTS
AND ENTERTAINMENT MR KIM IS AN
ACTOR DIRECTOR AND EXECUTIVE
PRODUCER THE CHAMPIONS
DIVERSITY AND ASIAN AMERICAN
REPRESENTATION IN HOLLYWOOD IN
FRONT OF AND BEHIND THE CAMERA
MR KIM SERVES AS AN IMPORTANT
VOICE AGAINST THE CURRENT SURGE
OF VIOLENCE TOWARDS PEOPLE. OF
ASIAN DESCENT. OUR SECOND
HONOREE IS PIVOT THE
PROGRESSIVE VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
ORGANIZATION. THE ORGANIZATION
IS THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE
IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. PIVOT
SEEKS TO ENGAGE AND EMPOWER
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS FOR YOU
JUST AND DIVERSE AMERICA AND TO
SERVE AS A COLLECTIVE VOICE FOR
THE SAME. IT LAUNCHED NEW
WEBSITES TO FIGHT
MISINFORMATION ABOUT VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS AND TO SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. OUR THIRD ON
A RE IS CONNIE ONE SHE IS THE
HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN CIVIL
RIGHTS. SHE IS THE CO FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF AAPI
WOMEN LEAD. SHE HAS BEEN
WORKING TO END VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN AND GIRLS OF COLOR AND
NON BINARY COMMUNITIES FOR
NEARLY TWENTY FIVE YEARS. DR
ONE LEAD TO NATIONAL COMMUNITY
BASED RESEARCH PROJECTS ON RACE
GENDER AND VIOLENCE. OUR FOURTH
HONOREE IS DOCTOR ERIC UPON.
SHE'S THE HONOREE FOR
EXCELLENCE AND HEALTH. SHE IS A
CALIFORNIA STATE EPIDEMIOLOGIST
AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTER FOR INFECTIOUS DISEASES
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH. THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IS GIVING SPECIAL
RECOGNITION TO OUR FIFTH
HONOREES THE CREATORS OF STOP
áP I HATE. LAST YEAR IN
RESPONSE TO THE ALARMING
ESCALATION OF XENOPHOBIA AND
BIGOTRY RESULTING FROM A COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THEY FORMED A
NEW ORGANIZATION THAT INCLUDES
A REPORTING CENTER. THEY ARE
MONTHS YOU SURE CAN CARTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ASIAN
PACIFIC POLICY AND PLANNING
COUNCIL CYNTHIA CHOI INVENTED
PAN COVR EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS
FOR CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION AND DR RUSSELL RUSSELL
JONES. PROFESSOR OF ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDIES AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY.
MEMBERS LET'S GIVE THEM ALL A
HEARTY ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
REGULATIONS TO THIS YEAR'S
HONOREES AND THIS CONCLUDES OUR
OBSERVANCE OF ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE
MONTH. MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON
THE FILE AT THIS TIME. MEMBERS
IN FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOUR OH SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE MS CLARK SILVA
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS MISS CLARK SILVA EMAIL
ME. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT AB
SEVEN THIRTY A MEASURE TO
PROTECT CHILDREN IN
PROFESSIONAL SORTS BY
CREATING. CLEAR GUIDELINES FOR
THEIR AGENTS THAT ALIGN WITH
EXISTING PROTECTIONS FOR MINORS
IN ENTERTAINMENT. CALIFORNIA
HAS MANY AMAZINGATHLETES WHO
HAVE REACHED THE PROFESSIONAL
RANKS AS MINORS JUST ONE RECENT
EXAMPLE IS YOUNG A LIVIO MORE
TRAY WHO AT THIRTEEN YEARS OLD
ALREADY HAS A NIGHT CONTRACT
AND BECAME A PROFESSIONAL
SOCCER PLAYER. IN ADDITION TO
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES WITH THE
PASSAGE OF SB TWO SIX TWO OH
SIX LAST SESSION EVEN MORE
CALIFORNIANS YOUNG ATHLETES CAN
AND WILL PROFIT FROM THEIR NAME
IMAGE OR LIKENESS. THESE
ENDORSEMENT CONTRACTS WE WILL
WILL REQUIRE THE AID OF A SAVVY
SPORTS AGENT. SADLY WELL AS
WELL WE CELEBRATE SUCCESS SEXES
OF OUR YOUNG. YOUNG ATHLETES
RECENT EVENTS HAVE BROUGHT TO
LIGHT THE FACT THAT SEXUAL
ABUSE HARASSMENT AND
MISTREATMENT OF ATHLETES IS
SHOCKINGLY COMMON. IT IS CLEAR
THAT CHILD ATHLETES ARE JUST AS
DRIVEN TO REACH THEIR GOALS AS
CHILD PERFORMERS AND ARE
EQUALLY VULNERABLE TO THOSE WHO
WOULD PREY ON THEM. THERE
PROTECTIONS UNDER THE LAW
SHOULD BE EQUAL TO THIS BILL
USES AN EXISTING AND SUCCESSFUL
FAIR FRAMEWORK AND THE LAW FOR
REGULATION OF TALENT AGENTS TO
APPLY TO SPORTS AGENTS AB SEVEN
THIRTY WOULD PROVIDE THAT NO
ATHLETE AGENT MAY ENTER A
CONTRACTORS AND A MINOR TO ANY
LOCATION WHICH WOULD BE
HAZARDOUS. OR DETRIMENTAL TO
THEIR HEALTH SAFETY MORALS ARE
AT OUR EDUCATION OF THE MINOR.
CLOSING THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
CHILDREN AND PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS AND GIVE NEEDED GUIDANCE
TO THOSE AGENTS WHO REPRESENT
THEM IT IS SUPPORTED BY
ATHLETES AND COACHES AND HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN EACH OF ITS PRIOR
HEARINGS. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS PARKER SILVA SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. NEWS
ARTICLE ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
CHARITABLE. ALL MEMBERS OF IT
IS THAT OF A. WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM FOR A WAIT AB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO BY DOCTOR WOULD
COOPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD AN ACT RELATING TO
NURSING DOCTOR WHAT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO IS A FOLLOW UP TO MY
BILL LAST YEAR AB EIGHT NINETY
WHICH CREATED A PATHWAY FOR
QUALIFIED NURSE PRACTITIONERS
TO PRACTICE WITHOUT
STANDARDIZED PROTOCOLS. THE
BILL CONFORMS VARIOUS CODE
SECTIONS TO MAKE IT TO CHANGES
MADE BY AB EIGHT NINE AND
CLARIFY SOME ADDITIONAL ISSUES
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN AN
ASSEMBLY BNP REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THEY ELECT WOULD
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARPAL OF NARAL. CEREBELLUM ALL
MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT OF A- THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM FOUR
OH NINE AB EIGHT EIGHT NINE
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE BY SIN REMEMBER
GIPSON AN ACT RELATING TO FOOD
ACCESS MISTER GIBSON EMAIL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT EIGHT NINE
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR JOBS ARE EQUIPPED WITH
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO GAIN
EMPLOYMENT ELSEWHERE AND MAKE
THE COMMUNITY AWARE OF THE-UPCOMING STORE CLOSURE. AB
EIGHT EIGHT NINE WILL REQUIRE A
GROCERY STORE TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN NOTICE AND I ONE
UNDERSCORE A WRITTEN NOTICE OF
ITS INTENDED CLOSURE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BUT NO LATER THAN
SIXTY DAYS OR A HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF
THE STORE THIS WRITTEN NOTICE
WILL BE PROVIDED TO THE CITY
COUNTY WHERE THE STORE IS
LOCATED THE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AB EIGHT EIGHT NINE WILL ALSO
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO POST GROCERY
STORE CLOSURE DATES. ON THE E.
B. T. WEBSITE FOR CONSTITUENTS
ACCESS. COVERT NINETEEN THIS
PANDEMIC GROCERY STORES. WERE
CLOSED IN LONG BEACH DUE TO
UNFORESEEN COSTS BUT KROGER CO
KROGER STORES- GENERATED
BILLIONS IN PROFIT DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
ISSUED AN ORDINANCE MANDATING
THAT GROCERY STORE WORKERS BE
PAID AN ADDITIONAL FOUR DOLLARS
OF HERO PAY. AND THEN TO STORES
I'M CLOSE THE FILE WOULD TO IT
HERE TO THIS MANDATE. THIS HAS
LONG LASTING EFFECTS ON THE
PEOPLE WHO RELY ON NEIGHBORHOOD
STORES FOR HEALTHY FOOD AS WELL
AS AFFORDABLE FOOD. WE WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT TEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT ALREADY
STRUGGLES WITH FOOD
INSECURITIES DO NOT KNOW WHERE
THEIR NEXT MEAL IS COMING FROM.
WE WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
UNEMPLOYMENT APPLICATIONS THAT
INCREASE IT HAS INCREASED DUE
TO THIS PANDEMIC THIS PAST YEAR
THIS BILL IS FOCUSED BASED ON
FAIRNESS TO WORKERS AND TO THE
COMMUNITY THEY SERVE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON. I SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THE
ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. IT
IS OUT OF. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP. HIGHS
FORTY ONE. YES FIFTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM FOR TEN THIS IS FILE
ITEM FOR ELEVEN. AB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX BY MR COOLEY
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION MR KOHLI YOU MAY
OPEN. COLLEAGUES ARE GOOD
AFTERNOON I RISE TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX THIS IS A
SPECIAL THE STATURE TO ALTER
THE OF VOTING PROCEDURES FOR
THE SECOND REGIONAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT BOARD- IT WAS LAST
ADOPTED- UPDATED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. AT THAT TIME MANY
LOCAL AGENCIES WERE ACTUALLY
MEMBERS OF THE DISTRICT. BUT
THERE WERE SEVERAL
PARTICIPATING AGENCIES AND THAT
LEGAL DIFFERENCE LED THEM INTO
A WEIGHTED VOTING SYSTEM- AS OF
A RECENT CHANGE FOR THE CITY
WILL GROW TO BECOME A MEMBER
AGENCY. ALL THE AGENCIES
PROTEST FOR THE SAME BASIS SO
IT IS A ONE ONE ENTITY ONE VOTE
RULE WE ARE INSTITUTING BECAUSE
THE PROTEST FOR THE AC WE
SHOULD RESOLVE- AND- ARMOR. AN
AYE ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU
MISS COOLEY SEEING NO
DISCUSSION AVAILABLE OUT OF.
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE. IS
THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL THE RESERVES ADAM.
WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL YOU WHAT
I SIXTY TWO KNOWS. TO THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM FOR TWELVE AB SIX THIRTY
FOUR. BY MYSTERY OF CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY FOUR
BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO AN
ACCOLADE IN HOUSING THIS
CARILLO. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M PROUD 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THREE FOR A
MEASURE THAT WILL HELP ADDRESS
THE HORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BY ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO EXTEND THE
AFFORDABILITY TERM. FOR FUTURE
HOUSING UNITS THE QUALIFIED
DEVELOPER FOR A DENSITY BONUS
BEYOND FIFTY FIVE YEARS
CURRENTLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO ADOPT INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING ORDINANCES THAT REQUIRE
DEVELOPER TO INCLUDE A
PERCENTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON SITE OR PAY AN IN
LIEU FEE TO FUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ELSEWHERE IN THE
COMMUNITY HOWEVER UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW FOR DEVELOPERS
SUBJECT TO INCLUSIONARY SET
ASIDE REQUIREMENTS AND THE
DEVELOPER LEX TO UTILIZE THE
DENSITY BONUS PROGRAM THEN THE
AFFORDABILITY DURATION
DURATION. FOR RENTAL SET ASIDE
UNITS UNDER BOTH PROGRAMS WOULD
BE FIFTY FIVE YEARS AB SIXTY
FOUR SIMPLY CLARIFIES THE FOR
THE UNITS IN A DEVELOPMENT THAT
ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH THE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING ORDINANCE
THE COMING IN CAN BE LONGER
THAN FIFTY FIVE YEARS. IF THE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING ORDINANCE
REQUIRES A LONGER PERIOD I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK WITH CREAM SEEING
NO DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT
A VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS THIRTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES.
WHAT A PASS A RETAINER
FILE ON FOUR THIRTEEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FOR FOURTEEN AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR BY MS
FRIEDMAN QUICKLY. ASSEMBLY BILL
LEVIN TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT RELATING
TO SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS. THIS
FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER NUMBERS TODAY
ARE RISE 2% AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR WHICH CLARIFIES EXISTING
LAW TO ENSURE THAT THE
PERMITTING FEE CHARGED BY
CITIES AND COUNTIES FOR HOMES
AND BUSINESSES TO INSTALL
SOLAR. ARE REASONABLE AND
CONSISTENT I DO NOT HINDER THE
GROWTH OF SOLAR ACROSS THE
STATE THIS BILL RECEIVED Y.
PART BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAD
NO NO VOTES IN THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN SENIOR DISCUSSION OF
IT ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE. WELL. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE
IT MISS CERVANTES ITEM THIS IS
FILE ITEM THREE NINETY THREE.
A. B. NINE THIRTY NINE. THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES AND OTHERS AN
ACCURATE EVIDENCE MISTER MANTAS
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
THREE NINE THE DENIM DAY AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS BILL
FULFILLS A PROMISE OF DENIM DAY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BY
PROHIBITING THE SURVIVORS
MANNER DRESS FROM BEING
ADMITTED AS EVIDENCE OF CONSENT
IN A SEXUAL ASSAULT CASE IF WE
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THE MATTER
DRESS TO BE ADMITTED AS
EVIDENCE OF CONSENT. THEN WE
ARE ENABLING AND HEIRONEOUS
BELIEVE THAT VICTIMS CAN
SOMEHOW PROVOKE THE PERPETRATOR
FROM COMMITTING SXUAL ASSAULT
THIS ATTITUDE WRONGLY PLACES
THE BLAME ON THE SURVIVOR
INSTEAD F WHERE SHOULD BE
PLACED SQUARELY ON THE
PERPETRATOR WHO COMMITTED A
CRIME EVENT EVEN THE
POSSIBILITY THAT I WOULD A
SURVIVOR WAS WARY MAY BE
ADMITTED INTO EVIDENCE DURING
THE COURSE OF A CRIMINAL TRIAL
DETERS MANY SURVIVORS FROM
SEEKING JUSTICE. THIS ARE
ACTUALLY WAS A BILL THAT WAS
ENACTED IN FLORIDA AFTER
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE CASE IN
WHICH A PERPETRATOR WAS
ACQUITTED OF A CHARGE OF RAPE
AFTER THE FACT THAT THE
SURVIVOR WAS WEARING A SKIRT I
WAS ADMITTED INTO EVIDENCE
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE LEADING
THE WAY NOT FOLLOWING AND
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
SURVIVORS THIS BILL WILL
RECTIFY THE POWER IMBALANCES
THAT EXIST BETWEEN PERPETRATORS
AND SURVIVORS AND DECLARED
DEFINITIVELY THAT IT OFF IT
NEVER PROVIDES CONSENT EVER. I
AM PROUD TO SELL MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN THE LEGISLATURE LGBTQ
CAUCUSES CO AUTHORS OF THIS
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
MISTER. MISTER SAY OCTOBER THE
REAR THE- YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK
MISTER SPEAKER MA'AM OF THE S.
ASK IN SUPPORT AND AS A PROBLEM
BECAUSE- OF AB NINE THREE NINE.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO OUR- FOR
INJURED THIS. AND IT. AB THIRTY
NINETEEN REPLY WHAT WE KNOW TO
BE TRUE. NO MATTER AN
INDIVIDUAL IS WEARING NO MEANS
NO. WHEN A VICTIM OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT IS BRAVE ENOUGH TO
SHARE THEIR STORY THE QUESTION
OF BUT WHAT WERE YOU WEARING.
NOT ONLY BLAMES THE VICTIM FOR
PROVOKING THE ASSAULT BUT IT
ALSO SUGGESTED PERPETRATOR HAD
AN EXCUSE FOR HIS ACTIONS OR
HER ACTIONS. THERE IS NO EXCUSE
FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT IN SURVIVORS
SHOULD NOT BE MADE TO FEEL
GUILT OR SHAME ESPECIALLY BY
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM. WHICH
SHOULD BE WORKING TO PROTECT
THEM. AN OUTFIT DOES NOT GIVE
CONSENT AND REMOVING THIS
SUGGESTION FROM  SEXUAL
ASSAULT TRIAL IS LONG OVERDUE.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
SAY AIRTEL THIS BARRICADE HAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE THIRTY NINE I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
INCREDIBLE DILIGENCE. ON THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND
FINDING THIS PIECE OF LAW THAT
WE KNOW ALTHOUGH IT WAS BROUGHT
UP IN COMMITTEE THAT MANY
JUDGES WOULDN'T ALLOW THIS
EVIDENCE AFTER THE HEARING THAT
OUR LAW CURRENTLY ALLOWS I
THINK THAT WHAT THE AUTHOR HAS
SO APTLY FOCUSED ON. IS WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE A VICTIM OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
PUT THROUGH THAT HEARING WERE
OUTSIDE. OF THE PRESENCE OF THE
JURY WE PUT THE VICTIM ON THE
STAND AND WE DO A HEARING ON
WHAT THE VICTIM WAS WEARING
DURING THE RATE. THAT IS ENOUGH
FOR US TO SAY THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WE CARE ABOUT
THESE VICTIMS THAT WE WILL NOT
PUT THEM THROUGH THAT MISERY TO
RELIVE THE TRAUMA OF THEIR
RAPE. AND ENSURE THAT WE STAND
FIRMLY ON THE GROUND THAT
CLOTHING CAN NEVER BE EVIDENCE
OF CONSENT AND SO THAT HEARING
IS UNNECESSARY AND JUST RE
VICTIMIZATION OF THE PERSON WHO
HAS SUFFERED TOO MUCH ALREADY
SO I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HER WORK ON THIS MEASURE.
AND I PROBABLY SUPPORT EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU IS
BETTER A HAND. SEEING OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM MR CONTEST YOU MAY
CLOSE WE WISH YES AND I DO WANT
TO NOTE- COLLEAGUES TO A J. CO
SO THANK YOU TO ALL WHO ARE CO
OP OF THE MEASURE TO. FIRST UP
FOR ASK FOR EITHER. AND WITH
THAT THE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESERVE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS TO
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE AT
I. SIXTY NINE OH ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS BACK IN
REGULAR. FILE ORDER. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FOR FIFTEEN AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY. COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS AN ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT ISSUE
MATHIS YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY ADDS FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED CALIFORNIA INDIAN
TRIBES OF THE CURRENT LIST OF
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE A
RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL WHEN
PURCHASING SURPLUS LANDS. THE
CALIFORNIA SURPLUS LAND ACT
GIVES PRIORITY TO LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES BEFORE
PUBLIC BIDDING ON SURPLUS LAND.
FROM A LOCAL AGENCY. THE ISSUE
HERE. IS THAT THAT EXCLUDES
THESE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES IS ELIGIBLE AGENCIES.
AND IT SEVERELY LIMITS OR
TOTALLY PREVENTS THEIR PURCHASE
TO RECLAIM CULTURALLY AND
HISTORICALLY SIGNIFICANT LANDS
WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE OUR STATE'S
HISTORY AND POLICY TOWARDS
TRIBAL LANDS THIS BILL PROVIDES
A FAIR AND MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE RETURN OF
ANCESTRAL TERRITORIES TOO MANY
OF OUR STATE'S INDIGENOUS
TRIBES. MEMBERS ASK YOU TO
STAND WITH OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND V<c.cyan></c>
THANK YOU. I THINK IT'S MATHIS
SEEING NOTICE DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. LOCAL OPEN THE ROLE.
RESERVE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. THE WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS. FOR SIXTEEN FOR
SEVENTEEN. PASS AND RETAIN THIS
IS FILE ITEM FOR EIGHTEEN AB
SEVEN TWELVE BY MISS CALDERON
FOR COREY. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AMERICAN THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS- AB SEVEN TWELVE
OPERATES AS A TEMPORARY
INCREASE ON THE LIMITS OF
DELEGATED LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AUTHORITY CAN APPROVE FOR
PUBLIC CONTRACT CHANGE ORDERS.
THESE LIMITS HAVE NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN.
AND DO NOT REFLECT INFLATION
CHANGES IN CONSTRUCTION MARKET
PRICING AND CHANGES IN THE
SCALE OF PROJECTS WITH SEVERAL
EXPENSIVE COUNTY PROJECTS
ALREADY UNDERWAY AND PLANNED
FOR THE FUTURE AB SEVEN TWELVE
SIX TO DECREASE DELAYS. AND
HELP ACCELERATE THE COMPLETION
OF L. A. COUNTY CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS. THIS BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF COMMITTEE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISSPELLED
AROUND SEE NO DISCUSSION OF
EIGHT ON THE ITEM CLERK OF
MORAL. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTE. I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM FOR NINETEEN AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. COOKERY WITH
AMENDMENTS SOME AGO A THIRTY
TWO WITH MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM MISTER
BLOOM ON THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS RISE
TO PRESENT AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO
FOR THE PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
THE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MISTER BLOW.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
MEMONS AND WITHOUT A WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE PHONE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED.
BILLS OUT OF BACK ON FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM FOR TWENTY. AMBER'S
WE'RE GOING TO WITHOUT
OBJECTION MOVED TO TAKE UP MR
HOLDEN'S. RESOLUTION THIS IS
FILE ITEM. FOR THIRTY SEVEN.
ACR. FORTY ONE. AND THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENCE
FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
COVER NINETEEN DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS MR HOLDEN ON THE
RESOLUTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. MEMBERS THE LETTERMAN
ACT IS WIDELY REFERRED TO AS
THE BILL OF RIGHTS FOR PERSONS
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. IT
IS THROUGH THE LETTERMAN ACT
THAT CALIFORNIA MAKES AND KEEPS
ITS PROMISE TO CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES. DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS ARE THE
WORKERS WHO HELPFUL FILL THIS
PROMISE BY SPENDING THEIR
CAREER GOING TO WORK ASSISTING
COACHING. MENTORING ENCOURAGING
ADVOCATING FOR OUR CITIZENS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE AND TO HONOR THEM.
WHETHER ASSISTING PEOPLE TO
LIVE AS INDEPENDENTLY AS
POSSIBLE TO SUCCEED AT WORK OR
TO PROVIDE RESPITE AND SUPPORT
FOR FAMILIES THESE PEOPLE HAVE
DEDICATED THEMSELVES TO A LIFE
OF SERVICE TO OTHERS. TODAY
FOURTEEN MONTHS AFTER OUR
STATE'S LOCKDOWN STARTED DUE TO
COVERT NINETEEN. IT IS CLEARER
THAN EVER THAT THE TERM
PROFESSIONAL FITS THESE
INDIVIDUALS. THE LIVES OF THE
PEOPLE THEY SERVE HAVE BEEN
DISRUPTED WE HAVE COUNTLESS
EXAMPLES OF HOW DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS HAVE INNOVATED
ADAPTED AND MADE HERE ROURKE
PERSONAL SACRIFICES TO EASE THE
DIFFICULTIES FACED. BY PEOPLE
THEY SERVE. MANY HAVE BECOME
SICK OVER THE PAST YEAR MANY
HAVE ISOLATED AWAY FROM THEIR
OWN FAMILIES. FRIENDS IN ORDER
TO BE THERE AND MAKE LIFE MORE
BEARABLE FOR THE PEOPLE THEY
SERVE. I QUITE FRANKLY AM IN
AWE. OF THEIR DEDICATION AND
THEIR PROFESSIONALISM. AND I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I FAILED TO
MENTION THAT THIS WORKFORCE
REMAINS WOEFULLY
UNDERAPPRECIATED. HOW CAN WE
VALUE THESE HERE WORKERS WITH
MINIMUM WAGE PAY. SO LET US
RESOLVE TO HONOR OUR DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONAL HEROES NOT
ONLY WITH THIS RESOLUTION. BUT
ALSO WITH OUR OWN RESOLVE TO
WORK FOR RATE OF PAY
COMMENSURATE WITH THEIR LEVEL
OF DEDICATION AND
PROFESSIONALISM. MEMBERS I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS HOLDEN MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE RESOLUTION.
YEAH THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I
STAND IN BROWN'S OF THE C. R.
ONE. TANER DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS HAVE SUPPORTED
AND- WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
DURING COVERT NINETEEN.
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED THAT
THE DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN JUST
APPROPRIATELY AFFECTED DURING
THIS PANDEMIC AND AS A LONGTIME
ADVOCATE OF THIS COMMUNITY I
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK
PROFESSIONALS OFTEN GO WITHOUT
THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PASADENA FOR
INTRODUCING THIS RESOLUTION. TO
HONOR THE HER ROHLIK. WORK OF
THOSE WHO HELP PROVIDE SERVICE.
TO THOSE. WHO ARE SO OFTEN
UNDERSERVED. AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO CLOSE BY SAYING. IT'S
BEEN PATHETIC. THE LEVEL OF
SUPPORT THAT THIS BODY HAS
SHOWN. TO THIS PART OF OUR
POPULATION WE'VE DONE A LITTLE
BIT BETTER LAST YEAR. AND I
HOPE THAT WILL WE HAVE ALL
THESE SURPLUSES SUPPOSEDLY.
THIS TIME TO. INVEST IN THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN FORGOTTEN. THESE
ARE THE LAST GROUP OF FOLKS WHO
HAD THEIR BUDGETS RESTORED. AND
IT'S REGRETTABLE BECAUSE I'D I
DARE ANYBODY IN HERE. TO FIND
MORE DESERVING OF PART OF OUR
POPULATION. THEN THESE PEOPLE.
SO I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR-
IMPROVE SUPPORT IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR LACKING
MR FRAZIER. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I REALLY WANT TO
THANK OUR OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
PASADENA FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD ABOUT THIS
WAR THE WORK FORCE THAT GETS SO
LITTLE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT. IN THE
REFERENCE TWO TO UPHOLD AND
SUSTAIN A POPULATION OF PEOPLE
OF DREW DIRE NEED. A LOT OF THE
TIMES THE WE'VE HAD OUR
OPPORTUNITIES TO UPHOLD AND
SUPPORT THIS POPULATION.
THROUGHOUT THE THIRTY YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN TRACKING IT
LATELY IT'S BEEN A ROLLER
COASTER OF CUTS. BUT YOU NEVER
SEE THE RESTORATION OF THE CUTS.
WE'VE RELEGATED THIS WORKFORCE
INTO A MINIMUM WAGE WORKFORCE
ESSENTIALLY. AND SAYING THAT
THAT THAT'S ALL YOU GET. THAT'S
NOT FAIR THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
ARE WORKING WITH THE MEDICALLY
FRAGILE THE BEHAVIORAL ISSUES
THEY GET KICKED PUNCHED BITTEN
SPIT ON. AND THEY DESERVE
BETTER THIS WAS WORKFORCE
DESERVES AN AMAZING AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT. FOR THIS POPULATION I
WANT TO COMMEND NOT ONLY THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BUT ALSO OUR
SPEAKER PRO TEM WAS ALSO
PARTNERED WITH ME. ON THIS
EFFORT AND ARE CHAIR OF SOMEONE.
UNDERSTANDING THAT WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH THIS CRISIS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND AS STATED THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAD TO MAN THESE
GROUP POLLS. I HAD TO MEN THE
POPULATION FOR SUPPORT AT RISK
FOR THEIR OWN LIVES AND MANY
DID GET SICK. IN MANY ROUTE
HOMES FAILED. NOW I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO THE- DIRECTORS OF
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND THERE
AN ABSOLUTE FEAR THAT IF WE
DON'T DO SOMETHING NOW IN THIS
BOOK IN THIS BUDGET CYCLE THAT
THE WORK FORCE IS GOING TO
DIMINISH EVEN. MORE RAPIDLY.
THANK YOU AGAIN. MY COLLEAGUE
FROM PASADENA HOLDING THE TORCH
TODAY. IN ACKNOWLEDGING WITH
THIS WORKFORCE. IS TO BE
HONORED I APPRECIATE YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER FRAZIER DOCTOR WOULD
YOU TWO ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM PASADENA I
TO STAND TO SUPPORT ACR FORTY
ONE CODE NINETEEN HAS AFFECTED
EVERYONE OF US IN SOME WAY AND
IN SOME MORE THAN OTHERS THE
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE AMONG US
ARE PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
AND INTELLECTUAL THE BEST
DISABILITIES AND WE ARE HERE TO
RECOGNIZE THE DEDICATED. DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
SERVICES AND SUPPORT AND
SERVICES TO THEM DURING THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THIS
PANDEMIC HAD A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON PEOPLE IN OUR IT D.
COMMUNITY AND HE'S
PROFESSIONALS TOOK
EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES TO LEARN
HOW TO BE SAFE. AND TAUGHT
THEIR CLIENTS AND FAMILIES TO
BE SAFE AS AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE
DURING THE PANDEMIC THEIR
SKILLS COMPASSION AND CARE MADE
A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THE PEOPLE
THEY SERVE. ONE OF THE MANY
CENTERS THAT DO THIS IMPORTANT
WORK IN MY DISTRICT IS UKIAH
VALLEY ASSOCIATION FOR REBUILT
OR FOR HER BILL TATIAN. THEY
MISSION IS TO HELP PEOPLE WITH.
MEET THEIR FULL POTENTIAL AS
INDIVIDUALS AND PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS IN OUR COMMUNITIES THE
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE MORE THAN
THIRTY PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
DIRECTLY SUPPORTING THEIR
CLIENTS THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
BY ZOOMING. WORKING IN PEOPLE'S
HOME SUPPORTING THEM- TO WORK
AND BEING A PART OF THEIR
COMMUNITY. FOR THE MANY DIRECT
PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
SUPPORT THE IDT COMMUNITY. I
SUPPORT ACR FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD AND
DOCTOR ARAMBULA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I AM SO PLEASED TO
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM PASADENA
AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
COLLEAGUES AND STANDING UP FOR
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THE HARD WORK THAT
THE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS ARE DOING DAY IN
AND DAY OUT. AND WHILE IT'S AN
EASY VOTE FOR US TODAY TO VOTE
FOR THIS RESOLUTION IT'S THE
HARD BOAT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO UP LIFT THESE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS WHO TAKE CARE OF
OUR ID DE POPULATION. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
WHERE THOSE OF US ON THE FLOOR
HAVE A CHANCE TO RECTIFY THE
ISSUE WITH PAY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES RIGHT
NOW. I LOOK FORWARD TO ALL OF
US WERE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY WHO WILL ALSO
STANDS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
WORDS OF LAND TERMAN ACTS ARE
NOT JUST WORDS ON PAPER BUT
THAT WE AS A STATE ARE ABLE TO
UP LIFT OUR ID DE POPULATIONS
AND TAKE CARE OF THEM WITH THE
DIGNITY AND RESPECT THAT THEY
DESERVE. I HUMBLY ASK FOR
SUPPORT ON A C. R. FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU DOT RAMYA SEEING NO
MEMBERS RE. MR HOLDEN YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF. MY COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE RISEN TODAY TO. TO ADD
SUPPORT TO THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION. YOU ALL BEEN
CHAMPIONS. ON DEALING WITH THIS
ISSUE AND VERY CONSISTENT OVER
AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME. AS
OUR SUB BUDGET COMMITTEE CHAIR
HAS POINTED OUT. WHO HAS BEEN A
REAL CHAMPION I WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE THAT AS WELL AS- MY
FRIEND FROM. MR FRAZIER
WHATEVER IT IS BECAUSE- YOUR
SUPPORT. IT DOES MATTER I OKAY
PROTOCOL ASIDE OF MY- HAS HAD
FINGER ON THE OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS ISSUE AND HAS BEEN YOU
KNOW STEADFAST IN AND MAKING
SURE THAT- THAT ALL OF US HAVE
BEEN ATTUNED TO WHAT IS THEY
HAVE BEEN FLOWS OF THE
FINANCIAL ISSUES OF SURROUNDING
THIS AREA AND SO WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR DILIGENCE IN THAT
REGARD. AND LET ME JUST SAY
THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS WHEN YOU
HAVE SOMEONE IN YOUR FAMILY
THAT- IS DEALING WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IT
MAKES IT EVEN MORE PROFOUND AND
IT'S VERY CLOSER TO HOME AND I
DO APPRECIATE EVERY MEMBER WHO
AT ONE TIME OR ANOTHER HAS
REACHED AND UNDERSTOOD AND DIG
DUG A LITTLE DEEPER TO BETTER
APPRECIATE THE PEOPLE. WHO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES TO THIS
COMMUNITY BECAUSE IT IS A VERY
TOUGH JOBTHAT THEY HAVE BUT I
WILL TELL YOU THAT THEY TAKE
GREAT PRIDE IN IT AND NOW IT'S
TIME TO UP LIFT THEIR THEIR PAY
TO MEET THEIR EXPERTISE AND
THEIR DEDICATION ANOTHER JUST
NOTED TO MYSELF YOU'RE A C. R.
FORTY ONE FORTY ONE OF MY
DISTRICT NUMBER I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT ACTUALLY MEANS BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD THING SO I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. OF ACR
FORTY ONE AND I ALSO OPENED
ROLE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR.
IT'S A MISH HOLDEN THE FIRST
ROW WILL BE- OPEN FOR AUTHOR
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS IS FOR A CO AUTHOR.
ADDING ON EACH YEAR FORTY ONE.
FOR CO AUTHOR ON THE. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. WELL CLOSER
AUTHOR SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS BACK IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER THIS IS. AB
FOUR THIRTY AB FOUR THIRTY AB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
FIFTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
THE CRIMINAL PROCEDURE MISTER
CHILL YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER CALL AB TWO
FIFTY NINE SIX TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES HOLE BY
PREVENTING DEPORTATIONS BASED
ON FAULTY GROUNDS. WE'VE ALL
HEARD OF THE TRAGEDIES OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO AFTER SERVING
YEARS IN PRISON HAVING PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY THEY'RE
ABOUT TO BE RELEASED AND
THEY'RE CERTAINLY TRANSFERRED
TO ICE. WHAT WE DON'T HEARING
THOSE STORIES IS THAT MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS DID NOTE THAT
THE CRIMES THEY WERE CONVICTED
OF OUR REPORTABLE CRIMES- LAW
ALREADY SO. IT OF SOME IS GONNA
OF AT FROM. IMMIGRATION THE NEW
CONVICTION COULD BE LEGALLY.
INTO SIXTEEN LEGISLATURE
CREATED A PROCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS ON A WHERE. OF
THESE IMMIGRATION CONSEQUENCES
TO PETITION THE COURT. BUT THE
CAR PROCESS IS ONLY AVAILABLE
TO THOSE CONVICTED BY PLEA
BARGAIN. NOT TO THOSE CONVICTED
BY TRIAL. PEOPLE HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO A TRIAL
WE SHOULDN'T PUNISH INDIVIDUALS
FOR PURSUING TRIALS AND TRYING
TO PROVE THEIR INNOCENCE WE
KNOW THE CONSEQUENCES CAN BE
DEVASTATING FOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES. PEOPLE TORN FROM
THEIR FAMILIES HAVING THEIR
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP BLOCKED
BASED ON LEGALLY INVALID
CONVICTIONS. THIS BILL WOULD
SIMPLY EXPAND THE CURRENT
PROCESS TO INCLUDE INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED BY JURY TRIAL SO THAT
THEY CAN PRESENT EVIDENCE TO A
COURT THAT THEY FAILED TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMMIGRATION
CONSEQUENCES. AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MICHAEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU C. NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. THE
CLERK WILL THE ROLE. IS ABOUT
ALL MEMBER OTHERS OUT OF. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE. DESIRE TO THE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY NINE KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FOR THIRTY ONE AB TWELVE
SIXTY CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY DR CHEN
HE MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER FOR ALLOW ME TO PRESENT
AB TWELVE SIXTY THE SEVERAL
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IS LEADING THE EFFORT TO BRING
THE FIRST HYDROGEN AND BATTERY
POWER TRAIN IN NORTH AMERICA AB
TWELVE SIXTY WOULD HELP
BUILDING CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED SPORTY
ZERO EMISSION TRAINS BY
STREAMLINING THEM THROUGH
SEQUEL. LASSER THE LEGISLATURE
PROOF EXEMPTS FROM C. FOR
HYDRANTS STATION FOR BUSES NOW
AB TOOL SICK ONE CLUE MISS
TRAIN CHARGING. FOR RAIL THESE
PROVISIONS HELP BOTH SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORT SYSTEM AT
A TIME AND COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK RIVAL. THANK EXCHANGE.
SENIOR TO. OF A ON THE AUTO.
CLERK WILL. RESERVE IT ALL
VOTERS OUT OF. ALL MY OF THE.
IT IS OUT OF OUT. WELL CLOSE
ROLE TIDE ABOUT ICE. SIX FOR.
THAT MEASURE PASSED FIVE ITEM
THIRTY TWO IS AB NOW SIX. BY
MISTER HOLDEN. IN THE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINE SEVEN
SOME MEMBER HOLD AND ACT
RELATING TO DEVELOPMENT MAKING
OF- FOR. MR HOLDEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER FOR ME TO
PRESENT A TWO NINETY SO TODAY
AB TWO NINETY SEVEN WILL
CLARIFY THAT THE I BAKE MY
FINAL HOUSING A PARTNER THE
OTHER ONE ELLA PROJECT ONLY
WHEN HOUSING- IS A- FOR THE
OPERA. OF THE- ADDITIONALLY
NOPE OF THE HOUSING CAN BE
FINANCE WITH TAX BONDS TO
ENSURE THERE IS NO CONFLICT
WITH OTHER STATE HOUSING
FINANCE PROGRAMS. UNDER CURRENT
LAW AYE BANK IS AUTHORIZED TO
FINANCE A WIDE VARIETY OF
PROJECTS BUT EXPRESSLY EXCLUDES
HOUSING WITHOUT DEFINING THE
SCOPE OF THAT RESTRICTION OR
CLEAR INDICATION OF WHY. THE
ABSOLUTE PROHIBITION ON HOUSING
AND I BANK CREATES A FINANCING
GAP. BY EXCLUDING ALL PROJECTS
THAT CONTAIN ANY ELEMENTS OF
HOUSING. UNDER AB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN THESE PROJECTS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVALS. I THANK YOU MISS
HOLDEN. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM- HELLO. IT
IS OUT OF UP ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ADEBAYO. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL
TELL YOU WHAT I. THREE FIVE
NINE ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASS
THIS IS FILE ITEM FOR THIRTY
THREE AB THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
BY MR LEE. CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN SOME
REMEMBER LEE MACULATUM STRESS.
MISCELLANEA MAIL THANK YOU MR
THREE PRO ORDERS ARE
ESSENTIALLY STAY AWAY ORDERS
ISSUED AFTER INDIVIDUAL CITED
BY BART POLICE FOR AN
INFRACTION THREE TIMES WITH
NINETY DAY PERIOD OR ARRESTED
FOR VIOLENT CRIMES SUCH AS
SOLAR ROBBERY THE CURRENT LAW
AUTHORITY. SPECIFIES BART MAY
ISSUE PROVISION ORDERS ON BARK
PROPERTY IN THE CASE OF THE NEW
BART STATIONS THAT RUN THIRD MY
DISTRICT THE PROPERTY
INFRASTRUCTURES- OWNED BY
DIFFERENT TRANSPORTATION
ENTITIES AB THIRTY THIRTY SEVEN
WORKS THIS X. AT TO PROPERTY
WERE PART OPERATES BUT DOES NOT
OWN. RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU ASHLEE. C.
NOTIFICATION OF A ON THE AYE
CLERK LEVEL ROLE ON THE.
RESERVE A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OF
THE- ALL MEMBERS OF. IT IS.
ALL
MEMBERS OF THE RESERVE A.
MR
LEE MOVES A CALL. FILE ITEMS.
FOR THIRTY FOUR. FOR THIRTY
FIVE FOUR THIRTY SIX PASS AND
RETAIN WE'VE DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM FOR THIRTY SEVEN.
THIS IS. FILE ITEM FOR THIRTY
EIGHT AC ARE EIGHTY FOUR BY MR
COOLEY CORKERY ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
FOUR FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY RELATIVE TO FOSTER CARE
MONTH. MR COOLEY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AS YOU ARE EIGHTY FOUR WHICH
RECOGNIZE OF MAY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AS FOSTER CARE MONTH. THE
TECHNOLOGIST AT THERE ARE
NEARLY SIX EIGHTY THOUSAND.
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. TEACHER PLACED IN
FOSTER CARE DUE TO NEGLECT AND
ABUSE IN THEIR HOME LIVES. THEY
ARE OFTEN VICTIMS OF FACE
COMPLEX. WHICH STAYS WITH THEM
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES.
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. SUBSTANCE
ABUSE HEALTH ISSUES GENERALLY
HIGHER EDUCATION GAPS. THEIR
INCREASED RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
AND INCARCERATION. AND THE FULL
COVER NINETEEN. IS ACTUALLY
EXERT. MANY OF THESE ISSUES FOR
THE CHILL FAMILIES AND- IN OUR
TRY WILL OF. H. OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON FOSTER CARE. I
WORK TO BRING. LOW MENTAL
HEALTH FUND JUVENILE
INCARCERATION OF SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TO THE FOREFRONT
WHEN DISCUSSING HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES AND
NEEDS OF FOSTER CHILDREN.
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE ARE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION. AND THIS MONTH EACH
YEAR WE RECOGNIZE FOSTER CARE
TO BRING AWARENESS TO THE
ISSUES DIGITAL ON THE WAY
SERVICE. IN THE FINAL WE CAN TO
GO OUR FOR THROUGH ALL THE
SUPPORTERS THEY NEED. IN
TRANSITION PUT IT INTO
ADULTHOOD ARE STRICTLY FOR YOUR
I. RENEE'S ALREADY. AN S. FIRST
BE ABLE TO FOR COAL. THANK YOU
MUCH COOLEY. MISTER LACK YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED WELL OKAY. I
BRIEFLY BY SHE STAN IN SUPPORT
OF ACR FOR THE TECHNOLOGY MAY
AS CARE MY- THIS PRESS YEAR'S
CREATED UNIQUE CHALLENGES FOR
THESE YOU. THAT'S TO US TO KEEP
FOR THE OF WHO ARE IN OUR CHART.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY CALL
PRINTER THIS RESOLUTION
DIRECTLY ALL. WORKING IN. AND
APART THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LACK. SEEN
BUDGET DISK ON THE REST. THIS
COOLEY YOU MAKE FOR IF YOU WERE.
COLLEAGUES IN A PER WORLD OUR
CHILDREN GROW UP WHOLE IN LOGS
OVER. IN THE HOME THEY RESIDE.
THAT IS NOW THE CASE. AND THIS
WHOLE SYSTEM DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE A SEVEN IN WHICH HOME
IS NEVER AS PART- JUROR VOTE.
INVITE YOU TO JOIN HIS CORE.
MISTER POLICE THAT THE FIRST BE
OVER FOR CO AUTHOR. FOUR GLOBAL.
MEMBERS FOR CO AUTHORS.
COAUTHORS ON A C. R. EIGHTY
THIS FOR A CO AUTHOR. THIS IS
FOR FELLOW. CLARK. CLOSER ALL.
THERE ARE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS AT
IT WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES SEVEN THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER
WEIRD FILE ITEMFOUR THREE NINE
AB FIVE OH TWO SEPARATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH TWO BY
ASSUMING DAVID ENACTED IN THE
CALM INTEREST OF. MISTAKE EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MY
TODAY ARE TO PRESENT AB FIVE OR-
UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN IN A
AWAY LOW FOR ITS BORDER
DIRECTORS. IT THEY DO NOT HAVE
A P. TO RUN FOR OPEN FOR. THIS
MUST GO THROUGH ALL THE FINANCE
PROCEDURES OF HAVING ELECTION
THIS PLACES A HUGE BURDEN ON
THE HOAS AND ULTIMATELY THE
COST FOR THOSE. I NEEDED
ELECTIONS GET FUNNELED DOWN TO
THE HOMEOWNERS IF YOU YEARS AGO
THE LEGISLATION PASSED A
MEASURE TO ALLEVIATE THE
SITUATION BY ALLOWING H. ALWAYS
TO VOTE BY A COMMISSION IF THE
EXACT NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
SIGNED UP TO RUN FOR A POSITION
MATCHES THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS
OPEN. UNFORTUNATELY THAT
MEASURE ONLY APPLIED TO HOAS
AND WAS SIX THOUSAND OR MORE
UNITS SMALL HOAS. WERE LEFT OUT.
EIGHT FIVE A TWO IT'S A MATTER
TO ENSURE THE SAME WAY SEE MAY.
TO A CHOI OF IN SIZE. I SHOULD
NOTE THE THIS BILL DOES. CHANGE
ELECTION PROCEDURES UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES IF MORE
PEOPLE SIGNED UP TO RUN THAN
OPEN POSITIONS THEN THIS BILL
DOES NOT COME INTO PLAY. A
REGULAR ELECTION STILL HAPPENS
AB FIVE A TO PASS HOUSING
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK MISS
DAVIS. NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. CORPORAL. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. HIS
OUT OF A. YEAH. CLICK WELL.
CLOSER TIDE OF A I. SIXTY FIVE
ZERO. SEVEN PASSES PASS TEAM ON
FILE ITEM FOR. THIS IS ITEM FOR
ONE AB ELEVEN SEP FOUR. CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL LOW SEVENTY BY
SOME MEMBER GRAY AND IN HOUSING
MR GRAYSON THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MAY A ELEVEN FOUR WILL
ALLOW QUALIFIED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS TO
EFFECTIVELY USE THE STREAMLINED
APPROVAL PROCESS ESTABLISHED BY
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR MAKES CLARIFYING CHANGES
TO CLARIFY THAT THE THREE YEAR
SHOT CLOCK FOR DEVELOPMENT OR
MODIFICATIONS APPROVAL IS
PAUSED WHEN A CITIES TUESDAY
PROJECT IT ALSO SPECIFIES THAT
THE PROJECT MUST ONLY COMPLY
WITH THE OBJECTIVE STANDARDS
THAT WERE IN PLACE WHEN THE
PROJECT WAS APPROVED. WITH
THESE CHANGES AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR WILL ENSURE THAT
QUALIFYING HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS CAN EFFECTIVELY STRING
BE STREAMLINED AS INTENDED
UNDER SB THIRTY FIVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR THANK YOU
MISTER. ST NO TO OF A ON THE
ITEM CARPAL OF THE ROLE.
RESERVE VOTER MEMBERS ARE OF A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE.
WELL CLOSER ALL CHINA VOTE I
SIXTY TWO. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE.
FIVE FOR FORTY TWO THROUGH FOUR
FORTY SIX PASS RETAIN. FILE
ITEM FOR FORTY SEVEN IS AB
THIRTEEN NINETY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AN ACTOR LIVING
STATE LANDS MS BERNARD AT. YES
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN NINETY WILL
PROVIDE THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION WITH MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO GENERATE
ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR RETIRED
TEACHERS AND FACILITATE
RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPMENTS
ON SCHOOL LANDS EXISTING LAW
AUTHORIZES THE COMMISSION TO
SELL ISOLATED NON ECONOMIC
SCHOOLEY. AND USE THE FUNDS
FROM THE SALE TO PURCHASE REAL
PROPERTY THAT WILL I DO
GENERATE ADDITIONAL REVENUES
THE PROBLEM UNDER EXISTING LAWS
THE COMMISSION IS CONSTRAINED
BY THE EXISTING 5% CAP FOR THE
USE OF FUNDS TO PUT PAY AND
SALARY COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
LAND PURCHASES AB THIRTEEN
NINETY CLARIFIES THE COMMISSION
CAN PAY ROUTINE LAND
ACQUISITION COSTS. AND REMOVES
THE 5% CAP ON THESE EXPENSES
THE BILL WOULD ALSO BETTER
POSITION THE COMMISSION TO
AVAIL ITSELF OF OPPORTUNITIES
TO WORK WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO FACILITATE THIS
TO FACILITATE RENEWABLE ENERGY
PROJECTS WHICH WOULD HELP
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION TO CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE AND HELP
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE AND
FEDERAL THIRTY BY THIRTY
POLICIES. I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER. SEEING NOTICE OR DEBATE
THE ITEM. CLARK THE ROLE. THIS
IS TO THE ALL MEMBERS ARE OF.
PALMER VOTE. RESERVE A- KIRK
WELL CLOSER TYLER I NINE DOES
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES PASSER
TAMPA ITEMS FOR FORTY EIGHT AND
FOR NINE THAT BRINGS TO FOLLOW
ITEM FOR FIFTY. THIS IS A BE
FORTINO SEVEN BY MS BURKE
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN- OH SEVEN BIASA BURKE
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE AND
HEALTH. MISSED YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER REMEMBER AB
FOR SEVEN IS A MEASURE TO
PROVIDE OUR STATE NURSES THE
TOOLS TO RECOGNIZE ADDRESS.
BIASIN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
SPECIFICALLY AB FORTINO SEVEN
REQUIRES NURSE SCHOOL PROGRAMS
AND HOSPITALS INCLUDE IMPLICIT
BIAS EDUCATION FOR NURSES THIS
IS A THREE FOUR MEASURE THAT
WILL MOVE US CLOSER TOWARDS
BRINGING DISPARITIES AND
NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES
BROUGHT TO US BY BIAS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
BUILT. THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OF A ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAJEVO.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT OF A. CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FOR FIFTY
ONE. AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE BY
MR BERMAN. WHO'S ASKING FOR
SOME SPACE THANK YOU. COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS MR
BERMAN. THANKS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES WHEN KAMEL
HARRIS RESIGNED HER U. S.
SENATE SEAT IN ADVANCE OF BEING
SWORN IN AS VICE PRESIDENT IN
JANUARY IT CREATED A VACANCY IN
CALIFORNIA'S REPRESENTATION IN
THE U. S. SENATE FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THIRTY YEARS. BECAUSE
CENTER PRETTY WAS APPOINTED TO
A TERM THAT ENDS ON JANUARY
THIRD FOLLOWING THE NEXT
REGULARLY SCHEDULED STATEWIDE
GENERAL ELECTION EXISTING STATE
LAW ALLOWS HIM TO REMAIN IN
OFFICE UNTIL THE CONCLUSION OF
THAT TERM ON JANUARY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. TO FEDERAL
APPELLATE COURT OPINIONS ISSUED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN HOWEVER
HAVE RAISED QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THAT ASPECT OF STATE
LAW COMPLIES THE SEVENTEENTH
AMENDMENT OF THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. AB FORTY NINETY
FIVE AND SHORES THAT CALIFORNIA
LAW IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT BY
PROVIDING FOR AN ELECTION TO BE
HELD TO FILL A VACANCY IN
CALIFORNIA'S REPRESENTATION IN
THE U. S. SENATE. EVEN IF THE
VACANCY OCCURS DURING THE LAST
TWO YEARS OF THE U. S. SENATE
TERM IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE
GREATEST PARTICIPATION IN THOSE
ELECTIONS AND TO AVOID THE
COSTLY DISRUPTIONS OF
STANDALONE STATEWIDE SPECIAL
ELECTIONS WHENEVER POSSIBLE A.
B. FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE
GENERALLY REQUIRES U. S. SENATE
VACANCY ELECTIONS TO BE
CONSOLIDATED. WITH REGULARLY
SCHEDULED STATEWIDE ELECTIONS
WHERE THAT IS NOT POSSIBLE THE
BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES A
PROCEDURE FOR THE GOVERNOR TO
SCHEDULE. STATEWIDE SPECIAL
ELECTIONS TO FILL THE VACANCY
IF IT IS PRACTICAL TO DO SO
BEFORE THE END OF THE TERM SB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE A SUPPORT
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND THAT'S
A YOU CALIFORNIA. AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK MR BERMAN MISS
KILEY YOU'RE A- THANK YOU
SPEAKER I THIS BILL IS DUE
RESPOND TO A LEGAL UP THAT I'VE
FROM OUR LEAD TO COUNCIL'S OFF-
WHICH CONCLUDED. THAT THE
CURRENT PLAN FOR OUR ELECTED
SENATOR ALEX PADILLA TO SERVE
THE REMAINDER OF WHAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN KAMILLA HARRIS IS
TERM IS CONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING STATE STATUTE- BUT AS
ALLUDED TO BY THE AUTHOR IS IN
VIOLATION OF THE SEVENTEENTH
AMENDMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION. SO I'M GLAD THAT
WITH THIS BILL THERE'S A
RECOGNITION THAT WE NEED TO NOT
VIOLATE THE CONSTITUTION- BUT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO SOLVE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROBLEM IN THE
MOST ON THE DEMOCRATIC
CONCEIVABLE WAY BY KICKING THE
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED
ELECTION OF A REPLACEMENT
SENATOR TO THE LAST POSSIBLE
CONSTITUTIONALLY ALLOWABLE
MOMENT THAT IS IN COMBINATION
WITH THE NEXT REGULARLY
SCHEDULED ELECTION. SO THE
RESULT OF THIS SCHEME TO REDUCE
THE WILL OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IS IT WILL
PRODUCE A TOTAL ABSURDITY NEXT
YEAR WHEN YOU GO TO VOTE YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE THE SAME U. S.
SENATE RACE ON YOUR BALLOT
TWICE YOU'LL VOTE ONCE PER WHO
WILL SERVE THE LAST MONTH OR
TWO. OF WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
KAMILLA HARRIS IS TERM AND
YOU'LL HAVE A SECOND VOTE ON
WHO WILL SERVE THE NEW SIX YEAR
TERM IN MY VIEW THE BETTER
APPROACH WOULD BE TO HAVE AN
ELECTION AS SOON AS POSSIBLE TO
RESTORE CALIFORNIA'S FULL
ALLOTMENT OF TWO ELECTED UNITED
STATES SENATORS THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT. WHEN WE
HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO IS OUT
MUSING ABOUT WHO HE'LL APPOINT
TO REPLACE DIANNE FEINSTEIN WHO
HASN'T EVEN INDICATED THAT
SHE'S GOING TO RESIGN SO I
THINK THAT THIS BILL MOVES US
IN EXACTLY THE WRONG DIRECTION.
AND I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE.
THIS MISTER GALLAGHER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. YEAH I THINK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I THINK ANOTHER
THING TO POINT OUT ABOUT THIS
BILL IS IN DIRECT CONTRAVENTION
TO THE CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
THAT MADE IT WOULD HAVE DIRECT
ELECTIONS OF OUR SENATORS IT
USED TO BE THAT STATE
LEGISLATURES. WOULD PICK THE
SENATORS FOR THEIR STATE AND
OUR US CONSTITUTION WAS CHANGED
SHOULDN'T IT BE THAT. TO ME
THIS IS VERY ANTI DEMOCRATIC TO
SAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE. AN
ELECTION TO ALLOW TE VOTERS TO
CHOOSE THEIR U. S. SENATOR AT
THE AT THE MOST EARLY
OPPORTUNITY POSSIBLE. THAT IS
WHAT THIS WAS ALL ABOUT WAS TO
ALLOW THE PEOPLE TO DIRECTLY
CHOOSE. THEIR SENATORS NOT TO
ALLOW ONE PERSON. TO CHOOSE THE
CENTER OF THIS EVEN LESS
DEMOCRATIC NOW THEY WERE
ALLOWING ONE PERSON THIS
GOVERNOR WHO AS WE KNOW IS
ABUSED MANY OF HIS POWERS- HERE
RECENTLY. TO ALLOW ONE PERSON
TO MAKE THAT CHOICE FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. SO IF YOU'RE TO ME
IF YOU'RE SUPPORTING DEMOCRATIC
VALUES YOU SHOULD NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU. I THINK IT WAS
GALLAGHER MISS POWER K. HAND IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY I
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT DEMOCRATIC
VALUES. AND WHAT HAS HAPPENED
FOLLOWS DEMOCRATIC VALUES BUT
IN ADDITION THE MILLIONS THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE
SPEND ON EXTRA ELECTIONS BEFORE
WE ARE ABOUT TO HAVE A REGULAR
SCHEDULE ACTION IS A WASTE OF
CALIFORNIA'S TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
AND IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS ALIKE TO
BE AS RESPONSIBLE AS WE CAN
WITH THOSE HARD EARNED TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND THAT IS PART OF
WHAT THE AUTHOR IS DOING HERE
TODAY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NO OTHER. SEEKING RECOGNITION.
ON MR BERMAN'S BILL MR BERMAN
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I JUST A FOLLOW UP FOR
MY CALL AGAIN FROM AROUND- I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THIS IS NOT
ONLY THE FISCALLY PRUDENT BUT
EVEN FISCALLY CONSERVATIVE
THING TO DO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THAT'S THE FIRST
MISS BERMAN. WITH THAT CLERK
LEVEL ROLE ALL MEMBERS. IT IS
OUT OF A- ALL VOTERS OUT OF.
PAUL MEMBERS IT IS OUT OF.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE TIDE
ABOUT I. TWENTY FIVE KNOWS
FIFTY THAT PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FOR FIFTY TWO AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY SIX CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND ACTIVATING
THE CELLS MISS FRIEDMAN EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX
IS A CONSUMR PROTECTION
MEASURE SPONSORSHIP WE BY THE
COULD NINETEEN AFFECT ON
THEATERS WHICH THOUSANDS OF A
LIVE EVENTS WERE CANCELED
ACROSS THE STATE NOW MOST
TICKET SELLERS DID THE RIGHT
THING AND THEY OFFER PEOPLE A
REFUND OR THEY OFFERED THEM A
SUBSTITUTE PERFORMANCE. BUT
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE HAD
SITUATIONS WHERE SOME TICKET
SELLERS WOULD SELL A TICKET TO
AN EVENT THE EVENT WILL BE
CANCELED FOR SOME REASON AND
THEY EITHER WOULDN'T RETURN THE
PERSON'S MONEY OR THEY WOULD
SAY WELL WE HAVE A SUBSTITUTE
UP PERFORMANCE SO YOU HAVE TO
TAKE THAT RATHER THAN GET YOUR
MONEY BACK. THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE TICKET THE TICKET PRICE FOR
CANCEL EVENT BE REFUNDED WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF THE CANCELLATION
OF THE TICKET PRICE FOR
POSTPONED OR SCHEDULED EVENT
BEFORE WE REFUNDED WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF A REQUEST BY A
TICKET BUYER. IN ADDITION IT
REQUIRES A TICKET SELLER TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW IN ADVANCE WHEN
THEY BUY THE TICKET WHETHER OR
NOT THAT TICKET IS ABLE TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO A THIRD PARTY SO
THEY DON'T GIVE THE TICKET TO
UNCLE BOB ONLY TO HAVE UNCLE
BOB TURNED AWAY AT THE BOX
OFFICE BECAUSE. THEY WERE THE
ONES THAT HAD TO USE THAT
TICKET. TICKET SELLERS- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH. THE THEATER
IN THE TICKET SELLER TO GET TO
A VERY GOOD PLACE ON THE BILL-
LAW KERN. STATES THE A TICKET
BY MAY REFER. A REFUND AN EVENT
IS CANCER. THE CURRENT LAW.
DOES NOT STATE WHAT THE COST
SHOULD GET THEIR MONEY BACK AND
THIS IS A- RESULTED IN TIGHT IN
CASES WHERE PEOPLE CAN. TELLING
THEY'VE BEEN WAITING SO MONTHS
EIGHT MONTHS ARE YOU. TO GET
THEM BACK A TICKET THEY PERCH.
THAT'S ON EXCEPT. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
SIX THAT'S A CLEAR. AND
REASONABLE DEADLINE FOR TICKET
SELLERS TO REFUND TICKET BUYERS.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN. SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE.
DESIRABLE WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
I SIX NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE ARE DISPENSED WITH
FIVE ITEM. FIFTY THREE THIS IS
FILE ITEM FOR FIFTY FOUR HOUSE
RESOLUTION FORTY SEVEN BY MS
REYES CORKERY. HOUSE RESOLUTION
FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES RELATIVE TO THE TWENTY
FIFTH ANNUAL IMMIGRANT DAY OF
ACTION THIS RACE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MA'AM. TODAY I
RUN TO H. R. FORTY. WHICH THE
TO. MAY TWO FIFTH TWO TWENTY
ONE THE TWENTY FIFTH ANNUAL
IMMIGRANT DAY OF ACTION. ON
THIS IMMIGRANT DAY OF ACTION
IMMIGRANTS. ADVOCATES ALLIES
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
CONSTITUENTS ACROSS EVERY
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA WILL
GATHER TOGETHER VIRTUALLY. TO
BRING TOGETHER OUR COLLECTIVE
POWER IN SUPPORT OF THE FORWARD
THINKING AGENDA THAT UP HOLD
THE DIGNITY AND EQUITY OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IMMIGRANTS IN OUR
STATE SHERRI DEEP COULD NOT TO
COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA.
IMMIGRANTS IN OUR STATE.
ACCOUNT FOR APPROXIMATELY 10%
OF OUR WORKFORCE. AND MANY OF
THEM DO NOT HAVE STATUS.
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN HAVE AT
LEAST ONE IMMIGRANT PARENTS.
CALIFORNIA STILL IS HOME TO THE
NATION'S LARGEST IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY NEARLY ELEVEN MILLION
PEOPLE OR ONE IN FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THE IMMIGRANT DAY
OF ACTION ENCOURAGES LEADERS TO
CONTINUE EMBRACING STRUCTURAL
CHANGES THAT ALLOW FOR A FULL
INCLUSION OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND OUR STATE'S LAWS AND
POLICIES. IT'S A GREAT KICK OFF
FOR IMMIGRANT MONTH WHICH IS
NEXT MONTH OF JUNE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON H. R. FORTY SEVEN
AMOUNTS OF THE FOR. ROLE BE
OPEN FOR COHEN. FAMOUS REYES.
SEEING NO DISK OR DEBATE ON
HOUSE RESOLUTION IS RACES ASTON
OF THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
COOPER CARPOOL OF THE ROLE. IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR FORTY SO
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHOR. THIS FOR
CO AUTHORS. WELL CLOTHES ARE
ALL THERE ARE FIFTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
YOU MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE DO
HAVE ONE ITEM ON CALL WE ARE
GOING TO BE MOVING TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS A RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
FORTY TWO. ON THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. CORRECTION
THAT'S FOUR EIGHT TO FILE ITEM
FOUR EIGHT TWO. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS RETAINDOES ANY MEMBER
WISH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING
HEARING NONE. THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON RELATIVES
AMONG VETERANS. CLARK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. YOU CALENDAR. ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. THE
CLOSER ROLE J. ABOUT I SEVENTY
THREE KNOWS YOUR THE CONSENT.
IS A DOT. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. WE DO HAVE ONE ITEM THE
REMAINS ON CALL. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS ARE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
CONVERSATION OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF JUSTICE CRUZ REYNOSO
THE FIRST CHICANO APPOINTED TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT THE PASSED AWAY
PEACEFULLY ON MAY SEVENTH. JUST
AS RENAULT ALSO WAS BORN IN
BRICK CALIFORNIA INTO A MEXICAN
IMMIGRANT FAMILY I WAS ONE OF
ELEVEN CHILDREN. FROM A YOUNG
AGE HE WORKED IN THE FIELDS OF
SOUTHERN AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA. HE WAS ABLE TO
ATTEND POMONA COLLEGE ON
SCHOLARSHIP AND LATER JOINED
THE ARMY. HE WENT ON TO GET HIS
LAW DEGREE FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BERKELEY. AT ONE
POINT IN HIS CAREER HE SERVED
AS A LEGISLATIVE ASSISTANT IN
THE STATE SENATE. CRUZ HAD A
DIVERSE LEGAL CAREER SPANNING
SIXTY YEARS STARTING AS A SMALL
TOWN LAWYER IN EL CENTRO. HIS
PROFESSIONAL PATH TOOK HIM TO
SACRAMENTO WHERE HE WAS
ASSOCIATE GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
THE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION AND DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE. HE TAUGHT LAW AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF NEW MEXICO
BEFORE BEING APPOINTED AS
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE IN THE THIRD
DISTRICT COURT OF APPEAL. HE
BECAME JUSTICE RENAULT ALSO
UPON HIS APPOINTMENT TO THE
STATE SUPREME COURT IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO WHERE HE SERVED FIVE
YEARS. AFTER LEAVING THE COURT
RENO SO RETURNED TO PRIVATE LAW
PRACTICE AND ACADEMIA TEACHING
AT UCLA AND UC DAVIS. JUSTICE
RENAULT ALSO ALSO SERVED AS A
MEMBER OF THE PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
TRANSITION TEAM. CHRIS HAD A
PASSION A PASSION FOR PUBLIC
AND COMMUNITY SERVICE HE WAS
WELL RESPECTED AND HIS
DEDICATION TO THE COMMUNITY IT
LED HIM TO RECEIVE THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM.
IN ADDITION YOU RECEIVE IT
HONORARY HONORARY DOCTORATES
HAD TO LAW FELLOWSHIPS NAMED
AFTER HIM. IT WAS A WRIST OF
THE HISPANIC HERITAGE
FOUNDATION EDUCATION AWARD.
JUSTICE RAIN ALSO HAS BEEN
CALLED GRACIOUS IN DEFEAT.
HUMBLE IN VICTORY AND THE MAN
WHO DISPLAY PROFOUND HUMILITY
DESPITE HIS MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. CALIFORNIA HAS
LOST A GREAT MAN AND A PUBLIC
SERVANT WITH HIS PASSING. CREWS
ROUTE WAS PREDECEASED THE CEASE
IS WIFE AND MOTHER OF HIS
CHILDREN THE NAME AND BIASA
WIFE. HERE SURVIVED BY HIS
CHILDREN THREE NO RUNNING LOW
AND RAW. THE STEP CHILDREN THEN
HOLLY IS SOME GREAT TWO GREAT
GRAND AND THIS THEY GRAND. AND
TO IF YOU'LL NOTICE HAVE THE
FLAG AT HALF MAST IN HONOR OF
JUSTICE REYNOSO THANK YOU.
THANK MISS AGUIAR-CURRY MS CAN
YOU ARE ALL RECOGNIZE ON THIS
IS GERMAN MM. THANK YOU I ALSO
RISE ASK INTO. ADJOURNING THE-
OF A MAN WHO FOR A YOUNG LATINO
GROWING UP I'M- THINKING THAT
MAYBE SOMEDAY I COULD BE A
LAWYER PROVED THE ULTIMATE
EXAMPLE. AND I REMEMBER BEING
TOLD BY MY MOTHER THAT THIS IS
SOMEBODY WE LOOK TO AS HE ROSE
THROUGH THE COURT OF APPEALS IN
THE SUPREME COURT. AS WHAT WE
COULD DO THE CHILDREN OF
IMMIGRANTS HE HIMSELF A TRUTH
CHICANO LATINO KIND AND SOFT
AND INTELLIGENT AND COMMITTED.
AND THROUGH EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED TO HIM AND LET'S BE
CLEAR IT WAS TO HIM HE NEVER
LOST HIS GRACE. IT IS A MAN WHO
YOU CAN IMAGINE AFTER HEARING
THOSE STORIES AND GROWING UP
WITH SUCH A FIGURE AS SOMEBODY
LOOK FORWARD TO WHEN I WALKED
INTO MY- LAW CLASS AT UCLA AND
THEY HAD A CHANGE OF PROFESSORS
AND I ENDED UP WITH. JUSTICE
CREWS ARE YOU KNOW SO IS MY
PROFESSOR IN LAW SCHOOL. I
GOTTA BE HONEST IT WAS SUCH AN
OVERWHELMING- OPPORTUNITY FOR
ME THAT I. THAT I ALMOST GOT
TEARY RIGHT THERE AND SO I
SPENT A SEMESTER- LIKE EVERY
LAW STUDENT ASKING FOR HIS
ADVICE IN HIS OPINION AND HOW
WE SHOULD LOOK AT THE LAWN HOW
WE SHOULD LOOK AT ETHICS MILAN
HOW WE SHOULD LOOK AT BEING
VALUE. HAVING VALUE- ARE
STICKING STRONG PER VALUES AND
HE NEVER LOST HIS PATIENCE YOU
COULD GO IN A HUNDRED TIMES- TO
OFFICE HOURS TO ASK IN PRETTY
MUCH THE SAME QUESTION BECAUSE
I WANTED A DIFFERENT ANSWER. IN
IN IN HE WOULD TALK ME BACK TO
HIS ANSWER AND HE WAS SO
PATIENT AND KIND AND
INTELLIGENT. AND PROVIDED THE
PERFECT ROLE MODEL I'M SURE FOR
SO MANY LATINOS WHO WHO LOOK AT
THEMSELVES AND THOUGHT. BUT
NOBODY NOBODY IN MY COMMUNITY
BECOMES A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
WHAT HE DID. AND WHAT EXAMPLE
HE CONTINUE TO BE. AND SO FOR
ME- AND EVERY LITTLE GIRL AND
BOY OUT THERE WHO GREW UP- IN
THE EIGHTIES LOOKING FOR A ROLE
MODEL. AND HE PROVED EVEN
BEYOND THAT I REALLY SILLY
AFTER LAW SCHOOL RUNNING
INTIMATE EVENTS I REMEMBER
ONCE. HE HE TOLD ME WE HAD-
DON'T DON'T ASK ME IF I NEED
COFFEE I DON'T WANT TO SERVE MY
COFFEE YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE DONE
FAR TOO MUCH HE ALWAYS WANTED
YOU TO FEEL YOUR VALUE HE
WANTED YOU TO BE PROUD OF
YOURSELF BECAUSE HE ALWAYS WAS.
SO WITH THAT I THINK WE LOST- A
TRUE GIANT BUT A MAN WHO
PROVIDED SO MUCH EXAMPLE FOR SO
MANY OF US IN WITH THAT I ASK
THAT WE TURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU CAN. MR BONTA. YOUR
RECORD. THANK YOU MAY SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS. OUR RIGHTS TO THE
THEY WERE. THE WE ASK TO THIS
BODY TO DURING A MEMORY OF A
DEAR FAMILY JUSTICE THREE NO.
FORMER SURFER COURT JUDGE. YOU
WOULD HARD PRESSED TO REALLY
FIVE A EXAMPLE THANK HIS OF A-
IN A- THEN JUST AS A TRAINER.
AND DINNER SIXTIES AS A YOUNGER
TO HE WOULD TRAVEL TO THE CITY
OF COULD CHAU. THE CITY I GREW
UP IN AND- OF THE FARMER FROM.
AS A FORM FARMER FOR HIM SO
RIGHT NOW NEW FIRST HAVE THE
STRONG OF THOSE WHO TOIL IN THE-
TO FOOD ON OUR- JUSTICE RAIN
ALSO PLAYED CRITICAL ROLE SO
SAYS ARE CHAVEZ AND A LOT.
WORKED MANY OF LEADERS IN THE
FARM MOVED. HE GAINED.
RECOGNITION AS HEAD OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE THE LEADING LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATION IN THIS
COUNTRY. HE WAS THE FIRST
LATINO. TO HELM DOT
ORGANIZATION. ONE FATHER WAS
STUDENT I USED RIVER HE
BEFRIENDED CHECK DRESSES THAT
ALSO. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
GOVERNOR UP JUSTICE RIGHT
DRESSES THAT I KNOW SUCH A CAL.
STATE COURT. THE FIRST PERSON
OF WHAT NOW TO SAN TO SURE. ON
THE COURT IN OUR HIS. MY FATHER
WAS ONE OF MANY STUDENTS ACROSS
OUR STATE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
JUSTICE TODAY AND ALSO THE
STORE RECONFIRMATION CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS THAT CAN. THAT'S AND- A
LAW LASTING. WHICH OUR FOR. AND
JUSTICE THAT I KNOW. HE LOW PER.
OVER MY PARENTS WEDDING
CEREMONY. IN HIS LATER YOU.
AFTER LEAVING THE- SUPREME.
JUSTICE ALSO WHAT CAN HIS WAY
AS A PER. OF CONSTANT LAW BOTH
THE CEO AND USED DAVIS. IN
NINETEEN THREE THE UNITED
STATES SENATE APPOINTED HIM TO
SERVE AS A MEMBER OF THIS US
CIVIL RIGHTS COMMISSION.
PRESIDENT CLINTON LATER NAMED
HIM VICE CHAIR OF THE
COMMISSION. DOES AS THE RAIN
ALSO RECEIVED THE PRESIDENT'S
MEDAL OF FREEDOM OUR COUNTRY'S
HIGHEST CIVILIAN HONOR FOR HIS
LIFELONG EFFORTS TO ACHIEVE
SOCIAL JUSTICE. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ONE AS A MEMBER OF
THIS HOUSE I AUTHORED A BILL
RELATED TO THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT. AND JUST AS
THERAIN ALSO WAS KIND ENOUGH
TO PROVIDE ME WITH HIS COUNSEL.
A FEW YEARS AGO. DOES THE THREE
KNOWS TO DELIVER KEYNOTE
ADDRESS FOR LATIN NEXT IT INTO
MY ALMA MATER YOU RIVERSIDE.
WHERE HE DELIVERED THAT ADDRESS
DURING OUR TWO LATINO EVENTS.
SADLY IT WAS THE LAST TIME.
THAT I GOT TO SEE THIS GIANT OF
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND.
JURISPRUDENCE WE WILL FOREVER
HIS MEMORY. IN OUR MY- AND IN
OUR HEARTS. COLLEAGUES ASK
REVERSED. ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER VAN. THAT
OBJECTION RECOGNIZING MR
GALLAGHER TO ADD ON TO THIS IS
GERMAN AND MISTER YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
ADD MY COMMENTS AS WE DID
DURING THE MEMORY OF JUSTICE
CRUZ REYNOSO. WHO IS MY LAW
PROFESSOR AT UC DAVIS- AND WHAT
I REMEMBER SO MUCH ABOUT. THIS
MAN HAS IS HIS KINDNESS. HIS
DECENCY HIS PASSION. HIS
INTEGRITY. AND I REMEMBER HE
WOULD HE TAUGHT OUR REMEDIES
CLASS AND HE TAUGHT US THE
POWER OF IN JUNCTION- TO GET AN
INJUNCTION IN COURT TO. KAREN
AND JUSTICE AND HE USE THAT
TOOL VERY WELL- IN FIGHTING FOR
FARMWORKERS IN HIS CAREER AND
HE TALKED TO US ABOUT THOSE
STORIES AND IN MY LEGAL CAREER-
THE TWO HIGHEST POINTS WERE
GETTING IT WERE WHEN I GOT AND
JUNCTIONS IN THE COURT. AND IT
WAS WHEN HE WOULD SAY THAT HE
WOULD ALWAYS SAY WHEN YOU'RE
JUSTICE BONE. STARTS BOTHERING
YOU. AND YOU KNOW YOU GOTTA DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT- AS I STILL
ALWAYS REMEMBER HOW HE WOULD
SAY THAT- WHEN YOU'RE JUSTICE
BONE TELLS YOU TO DO SOMETHING
STAND UP AND FOR ME I ALWAYS
REMEMBERED CRUZ REYNOSO- IN
THOSE MOMENTS. AND FAST FORWARD
TO GET ELECTED TO THIS OFFICE.
I WAS ABLE TO HAVE ON MY STAFF-
JUST AS RENAULT'S THOSE
GRANDSON STEVEN. AS A MEMBER OF
MY STAFF AND HE NOW WORKS FOR
SENATOR NIELSEN- AND WE WERE
ABLE TO HAVE MR AND ALSO ON
THIS FLOOR JUST A COUPLE YEARS
AGO- WE WERE RECOGNIZING HIM.
AND WHAT A MOMENT THAT WAS
TRULY A GIANT- BUT JUST A MAN
OF JUST TOTAL DECENCY AND I AND
I KNOW THAT- IT'S A SAD DAY FOR
US IN THIS. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT I KNOW THAT. HE
IS HEARING THESE WORDS WELL
DONE. GOOD AND FAITHFUL SERVANT.
MAYBE IT JOURNAL MEMORY. OF
JUSTICE CRUZ REYNOSO. THANKS
GALLAGHER AND MISS RADIUS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TO RISE AND ALSO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF. JUSTICE
CRUISING ALSO. I WANT TO RISE
ALSO AND I THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FOR ASKING US TO TURN IN HIS
MEMORY AND TO HONOR THE LEGACY
OF THIS GREAT MAN JUSTICE
CRUISING ALSO FROM HIS EARLY
DAYS AS A CHILD. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HE FOUGHT TO AND DO
THE PERVASIVE RACIAL
INJUSTICES. THAT AT THAT TIME
WERE TOO OFTEN COMMONLY
ACCEPTED AS NORMAL. HE TOOK HIS
ANGER REGARDING INJUSTICES AND
PURSUED LONG AND A LAW DEGREE.
AND ONE THING THAT HE WOULD SAY
IS I HAD AN URGE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE INJUSTICES
BUT I SAW AROUND ME. AND HE DID
IT. ON A PERSONAL LEVEL HE
WASN'T MY LAW PROFESSOR BUT
SURE I SURE WISH SHE HAD BEEN.
BUT I LEARNED SO MUCH FROM HIM
HE AND I WERE BOTH FEATURED IN
A BOOK CALLED LIBERAL THE LIST
THE LENTILS. THIS IS A BOOK
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO CAME FROM A
PARTICULAR TOWN IN MEXICO HOW
DOES THE PEOPLE ON HOW THE
SCHOOL. HE WAS FROM OUR
HOMETOWN. M. THAT WHAT HE AND I
SHOULD STORY ARE GOOD THAT THE
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN THAT BOOK.
HE WAS SPECIFICALLY FROM RUN.
ALSO WAS A PART OF. HELLO STILL
PEOPLE. EVERY TIME I RAN
SOMEHOW WOULD RUN INTO HIM AND
HE ALWAYS REMIND ME THAT HE WAS
THERE TO ENDORSE ME TO SUPPORT
ME THAT MEANT A LOT TO ME. HE
SOMEBODY THAT I'VE LOOKED UP TO
AND EVERY EVERY ASPECT OF MY
CAREER AS AN ATTORNEY AND NOW
AS A PUBLIC SERVANT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I JOIN WITH ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR TALKING ABOUT
HIS HISTORY AND I THANK MY
HIS HUMANITY. HIS HUMILITY HIS
DIGNITY HIS GRACE BECAUSE THAT
IS WHO HE WAS. COLLEAGUES I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN JUSTICE
CUSHING ALSO IS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISS REYES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
REQUEST OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND AT TWENTY
FOUR RESIDENT BILL BUSSY. BORN
IN PRESCOTT ARIZONA IN NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN BILL GRADUATED
HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE NEAR THE END OF WORLD WAR
TWO AND IMMEDIATELY JOINED THE
US NAVY. HE WAS SENT TO U. S.
C. FOR TWO YEARS TO TRAIN AS A
PILOT. AND IT WAS THERE THAT HE
MET HIS FUTURE WIFE BARBARA.
AFTER SERVING AS A JET FIGHTER
PILOT IN BOTH WORLD WAR TWO IN
THE KOREAN WAR. HE BARBER PLAN
TO HEAD BACK TO U. S. C. WERE
BOLD FINISHES COLLEGE DEGREE.
HOWEVER THEY STOPPED IN PALO
ALTO TO VISIT BARBARA'S SISTER.
AND THEY NEVER LEFT. BILL
BARBER DECIDED TO STAY IN PALO
ALTO AND BILL ATTENDED STANFORD
UNIVERSITY. EARNING BACHELOR'S
AND MASTER'S DEGREES IN
ARCHITECTURE. BORN ON THE
DESIGN MANY WELL KNOWN
BUILDINGS ON STANFORD CAMPUS IN
PALO ALTO INCLUDING THE
DOWNTOWN PALO ALTO LIBRARY IN
THE LUCY EVANS BEILINSON NATURE.
CENTER BUT HIS FAVORITE WAS THE
TRUST MEMORIAL UNION BUILDING A
MAIN CAMPUS HANG OUT FOR
STUDENTS. AS ACCOMPLISHED AS HE
WAS IN HIS CAREER BILL WAS EVEN
BUSIER IN RETIREMENT. HE SERVED
ON THE POLITICS HOUSING
COMMISSION AS VICE PRESIDENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
POLE TO CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AS
PRESIDENT OF THE POLL TO YMCA
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND IS
PRESIDENT OF THE ROTARY CLUB.
WHERE HE WAS ACTIVE WELL INTO
HIS NINETIES. IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN BILL RECEIVED THE
PRESTIGIOUS AVENUE THIS
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD.
WELL BILL AND BARBARA TRAVELED
ALL OVER THE WORLD BOTH FOR
WORK AND PLEASURE THEIR
SWEETEST ENDEAVOR WAS HOSTING
AN ANNUAL PEACH ICE CREAM
SOCIAL FOR THE PROFESSOR
PROFESSOR BILL NEIGHBORHOOD. IN
AN ARTICLE ABOUT HIS LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD BILL SAID I'M
PROUDEST OF MY FAMILY OF COURSE
HE SAID WE HAVE GREAT KIDS
GREAT GREAT GRANDKIDS AND GREAT
GREAT GRANDKIDS. I CAN ATTEST
TO THAT ONE OF BILLS
GRANDDAUGHTERS BECCA IS ONE OF
MY BEST FRIENDS. IN FACT BACK
AS NO IDEA I'M DOING THIS RIGHT
NOW BUT RANDOMLY TEN MINUTES
AGO TEXAN ME A SCREEN SHOT.
THAT BILL HAD CAPTURED ON A
CAMCORDER OF ME AND BACK AND
BACK IN HIGH SCHOOL THAT YOU
JUST RANDOMLY TEXTED ME TEN
MINUTES AGO. TEN MINUTES AGO.
IT WAS THROUGH BECCA THAT I
FIRST MET BILL IN BARBARO WHEN
I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL AND WE'RE
GOING TO AFFECT AND I WILL GO
ON TO AFFECTIONATELY REFER TO
BARBARA IS GRANDMA. WHICH SHE
ALWAYS GOT A KICK OUT OF.
EVENTUALLY MY GRANDPARENTS
WOULD MOVE INTO THE SAME SMALL
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY THAT BILL
AND BARBARA LIVED IN. I WASN'T
SURPRISED AT ALL TO LEARN THAT
BILL HAD BECOME THE UNOFFICIAL
SOCIAL CHAIR OF THE COMMUNITY.
WHENEVER I HAD DINNER WITH MY
GRANDPARENTS THEIR BILL WOULD
ALWAYS STOP BY OUR TABLE TO
VISIT. AND AFTER MY
GRANDPARENTS PASSED AWAY. I
WENT BACK A FEW TIMES TO HAVE
DINNER WITH BILL. BARBARA AND
THEIR KIDS GRANDKIDS AND GREAT
GRANDKIDS. BILL IS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE NICEST PEOPLE I'VE EVER
MET. AND WAS RENOWNED FOR HIS
UNENDING OPTIMISM. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE BARBARA
HIS KIDS GRANDKIDS AND GREAT
GRANDKIDS. I WILL TRULY MISS
RANDOMLY BUMPING INTO AROUND
TOWN. I REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR BERMAN.
AND MR GIBSON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED UNDER GERMAN
AMERICAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I
ACTUALLY THOUGHT I WOULD NEVER
BE DOING THIS. WHILE ON THIS
FLOOR. MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK
HIS BODY TO ADJOURN ON BEHALF
OF MY GOOD FRIEND. MY BROTHER
BY A MODEL. PATRICK DWAYNE
JOHNSON. HIS REAL NAME IS
PATRICK THIS IS LEGAL NAME.
WE'VE ALWAYS BECAUSE I'VE KNOWN
HIM DOING. DWAYNE WAS A SOLEMN
THIS FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY
NOT KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS HE
MUSIC WAS HIS LIFE. WHO MADE A
MONUMENTAL IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE. THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE UNITED
STATES. AS A WHOLE. HIS
MINISTRY SPANS ACROSS
DENOMINATIONS. IN THE FAITH
BASED COMMUNITY AND HAS LEFT AN
INDELIBLE MARK ON THOSE THAT
ENCOUNTERED. HIS MUSIC OR JUST
BEING IN HIS PRESENCE. SINCE
THE TRIAL SAYS A CHILDHOOD DAYS.
HE WAS A SINGER AT GREATER
WAYSIDE CHURCH OF GOD IN CHRIST
DUWAYNE SORT AS A RECORDING
ARTIST. I SONG WRITER A GUEST
SINGER. A WORSE A PRAISE AND
WORSHIP LEADER A TEACHER EVEN A
SONG THIS. AND YES HE WAS
ORDAINED MINISTER AS WELL OF
THE GOSPEL. GETTING LOST IN HIS
PRAISE AND WORSHIP. WAS
EVERYTHING TO DO WAYNE TWO IS A
LIFE. BUT HIS PROUDEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT WAS THE LIBERTY
OF BEING A PRAISE AND WORSHIP
LEADER. AND SO MANY JOHN ROSE
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
HE WAS KNOWN. AN EMBODIMENT
CRISIS. YES EVEN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SPEAKING WITH OTHER
PASTORS WHO SAID DIDN'T TO
WAYNE WAS DOING YOUR PRAISE AND
WORSHIP LEADER AT HER CHURCH
AND I SAID YES. WE HAD SO MANY
STORIES ABOUT THE WAYNE. AND
ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE THAT HE'S
TOUCHED THROUGH HIS MUSIC AS A
SALAS. AS MUCH AS HE LOVED THE
GOSPEL MUSIC COMMUNITY NOTHING
ECLIPSE HIS LOVE FOR HIS WIFE
CERITA. HIS WIFE OF TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS. HIS CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN THE WAYNE IT WAS
A GENERAL IN THE LOS ANGELES
GOSPEL COMMUNITY AND THE IMPACT
OF HIS VOICE WILL CONTINUE TO
LIVE ON. AND AS I CLOSE I
REMEMBER THE LAST TIME I SAW
THE WINNING WAS ON MARCH THE
FIFTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
AS I ASKED HIM TO STAY SAYING
AT THE CELEBRATION OF LIFE FOR
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES DUE
TO THIS PANDEMIC. IN MY
DISTRICT. AND MEMBERS OF HIS
LAST SONG THAT I REMEMBER. WAS
GOING UP YONDER. TO BE WITH MY
LORD. IT TOUCHED US ALL.
MEMBERS I KNOW THAT GOD HAS HIM
ALREADY DIRECTING THE PRAISE
AND WORSHIP TEAM AND HAVING.
HE'S PUTTING TOGETHER THE BEST
CHOIR FOR GOD. I RESPECTFULLY
ASKS IT WILL TURN IN MEMORY. MY
GOOD FRIEND AND BROTHER DWAYNE
JOHNSON. THANK YOU MISS GIPSON.
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS. MEMBERS
I AM AT THIS TIME PREPARE TO
LIVE THE CALL. ON AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
POST. WISH TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED WHICH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL. YEAH. FEDERAL TELL YOU
THAT I SIXTY NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WILL BE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY MA
TWENTY FIFTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY SIX CHECK
IN SESSION THURSDAY MAY TWENTY
SEVENTH FLOOR SESSION BEGINS AT
ONE PM FRIDAY MAY TWENTY EIGHT
FOUR SESSION WILL BE AT NINE
AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUE SEEING
AND HEARING A FOR THE BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN MISTER BLOOM MOVES
MR GALLAGHER SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY MAY THE TWENTY SEVENTH
AT ONE PM AND THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PERKS.
AB EIGHT EIGHT NINE I TO NON
VOTE. BURKE CHANGES MEMBER
QUIRK SO SOME EIGHTY NINE I'D
LOADING.
OKAY. BOTH CHANGE
MESSAGING. I DON'T FOUR THIRTY
AB. TWELVE FIFTY NINE. I DO NOT
VOTING. BOTH CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI CYNICAL
TWELVE FIFTY NINE I DO NOT
VOTING.